“There’s an app for that!”
It was a phrase so ubiquitous in the early
days of the smartphone craze that it’s hard
to believe Apple actually has it trademarked.
It was a testament to a simple and immutable
truth about the world these new touchscreen
phones were creating: No matter how strange
and obscure the need, there would be an app
to fulfill it.
Perhaps you remember iBeer - The app that
allowed you to pretend you were drinking a
tall glass of beer…
For some reason.
There was Carrr Matey, an app that reminded
you where you parked your car…
In a pirate voice.
And who could forget “I Am Bread”, a surreal
game about controlling a sentient slice of
bread on a quest to become toast.
But there’s one app out there somewhere
on the market that you probably didn’t download.
And if you did, well, you have our sincerest
apologies, because even seeing this video
pop out onto your feed probably sent a chill
down your spine - Well, if that chill ever
even left.
Take it from one gentleman whose life took
a very strange turn after downloading a certain
app that the SCP Foundation calls SCP-1471.
Because the sentiment “There’s an app
for that” doesn’t exclude experiencing
mortal terror…
Joe Lillis, an insurance salesman from Milwaukee,
had just gone through another atrocious date.
After a mediocre meal and an uncomfortable
35 minutes of inane babble, sensing the whole
time that she really wasn’t that interested,
his date excused herself to take a quick phone
call outside.
Sadly for Joe, she never returned, leaving
him to pick up the check.
Of all the many words you could use to describe
poor Joe Lillis, the most pertinent would
be “lonely.”
Ever since Carol, his wife of ten years, had
passed away in a freak accident, he’d been
trying to find some kind of way to fill the
void.
They’d been high school sweethearts, intent
on spending the rest of their lives with one
another.
As fate would have it, only Carol would get
that tainted luxury.
Joe would be forced to endure life after the
joy of living had run its course.
He only hoped he might be lucky enough to
find love again.
However, Joe was on the wrong side of forty,
and as so many others his age were already
hitched, he could feel his options going out
one by one.
Would he be destined to live out the rest
of his days alone?
Joe didn’t feel like spending the back half
of his life catching reruns of Seinfeld and
tending to his fish; he needed to get out
of there.
And thankfully, like the rest of us, he lived
in the internet age - He had more apps, websites,
online services, and hot russian singles in
his area than he knew what to do with.
So, surely, one would have the right person
for him!
He’d tried them all: Tinder, Hinge, Match.com,
Plenty of Fish, eHarmony, Bumble, Zoosk, OKCupid,
Friend Finder, Deeply Lonely Singles with
Low Expectations.com, and so much more.
However, all it seemed to achieve was setting
him up for more disappointment.
None of the dates he’d managed to get ever
resulted in anything getting serious.
Heck, it was a minor miracle if he managed
to get any of them on a second date.
Was this it?
Was this his life now?
Had he only ever gotten one shot at love,
and the grasping claws of fate yanked it away
from him without a second thought?
Would life continue on the hamster wheel of
loneliness - sleeping, getting up, eating,
working, and sleeping again, every day getting
somehow both faster and slower as life trudged
on to a disappointing yet inevitable conclusion?
What a terrible fate to find yourself trapped
in…
Whenever Joe started feeling maudlin like
this, he knew it was time to get proactive
again.
Maybe the right woman was out there - there
were billions of them, after all, surely at
least one of them would be the perfect person
for him.
He just needed the perfect app…
He’d burned through all the most reputable
apps already, and was now perusing some of
the slightly seedier options - most of which
were likely data mining fronts from the Balkans.
However, as generic app after generic app
passed, something different caught his eye.
The icon was a smiling cartoon dog, and its
name was MalO Version.
1.0.0.
This gave him a little chuckle.
At the very least, it was very different branding
from the rest of the dating apps he’d seen.
Maybe it’d just been sorted into the wrong
section of the app store?
He decided he’d click it and take a look
at the app’s description.
The description read:
“Never settle for those awkward feelings
of being alone ever again.
MalO is an exciting and interactive experience
that will keep you engaged and intrigued.
The anxiety of social
situations can be nerve-racking,
but after just a few hours of MalO you will
soon forget all about those painful emotions
of disappointment.
Be part of the new craze that is quickly becoming
the next social substitute.
Remember, the more you participate, the more
MalO will engage you.
Your experience is completely up to you.
Absolutely NO ADS.
Enjoy!”
Well…
It certainly provoked Joe’s curiosity, at
the very least.
He did want to banish his feelings of loneliness,
and seeing as the app was free and apparently
had no ads, he’d surely be foolish to not
at least give it a whirl.
What’s the worst that could happen?
He began the installation and only then noticed
that the app had no listed developer.
It took up 9.8 MB of memory, which he wasn’t
tech savvy enough to see any issues with.
More than anything, Joe was just enticed by
the prospect of finally having another chance
at companionship with MalO.
After all, it is the “next social substitute”,
whatever that means.
However, Joe’s excitement was quickly quashed
when he hit the home screen button, and noticed
that the icon for the app
never actually materialized.
Strange.
He checked the app store portal again and
saw that, according to
them, the app had completely
downloaded.
What gives?
Was it a glitch, or was MalO actually just
malware?
Either way, he was disheartened by the fact
that this immaterial app certainly wouldn’t
be getting him any companionship.
Or so he thought, anyway.
Joe was used to disappointment by now, so
he didn’t take the hit too personally.
He decided to just play out the rest of his
evening on autopilot: Making himself some
soup, doing the laundry, watching more Seinfeld
reruns, taking a cold shower, and preparing
to cry himself to sleep again.
MalO was already becoming a distant memory,
just like all deceptive sources of hope.
But one strange thing happened that disrupted
Joe’s finely-tuned evening routine.
He received a text message.
This was incredibly strange, because nobody
ever seemed to text him.
The last text he got was from Carol, just
before her accident, so it was almost surreal
to hear that alert sound now, after everything
that’d happened.
He checked and saw that the text was an image
attachment sent from an unknown number.
Perplexed yet curious, he decided to open
it.
His curiosity soon gave
way to a kind of melancholy
nostalgia when he saw that the photo was of
his and Carol’s favorite cafe in town.
They’d spent many a morning there, back
when she was alive.
Treating themselves to a nice cup of coffee
and perhaps a croissant.
Just seeing it again caused an involuntary
smile to spread across his face.
It never even occurred to him, as it probably
would have to others, that this could be seen
as a little creepy.
He hadn’t frequented the bakery since Carol
died.
How would anyone even know that the place
held any significance for him?
Was it a stalker?
A ghost?
Or just a spooky coincidence?
None of these thoughts even crossed Joe’s
mind.
He was just grateful for the surprising reminder
of the happiness he’d once had.
For the next couple hours, things seemed…
Lighter.
He went about his evening, checking the photo
every so often and smiling, until eventually
he found himself in bed, still looking into
the glow of his phone.
It was such a beautiful little cafe…
Then, he froze.
He noticed something in the picture.
It’d been there the whole time, but only
now was he seeing rather than just looking.
It was in the corner, staring through the
glass of the cafe’s door.
So faint he almost wanted to dismiss it as
a trick of the light.
It was a face - Well, not a face, more like
a skull.
Not human, not anywhere near human.
Long, slender, and canine, with protruding
fangs and vacant white eyes.
The pure white of the skull was buried in
a nest of thick, black hair.
It looked like it was crouching behind the
door, looking out, and grinning, whatever
the hell it was.
Just seeing it changed the entire tone of
the picture.
It was no longer a simple reminder of bygone
joy.
Now, all that was radiating out of that image
was a palpable sense of dread.
Was someone playing some kind of awful prank
on him?
Just then, he was jogged from his contemplation
by another alert.
A new message from the same number as before.
With great hesitation, he hovered his thumb
over the push notification and clicked.
That’s when everything got a lot worse.
It was a photo of a bus stop.
Not just any bus stop, of course, it was Stop
C16 - The one that Joe always took to get
to work.
It looked like it was taken relatively early
in the morning, but nobody was there.
Well…
Not quite nobody.
There was that figure again.
It stood at full height, behind the partially
frosted glass that makes up the back of the
bus stop.
That same large, black humanoid shape, with
a white, grinning dog skull where the face
should be.
Something about it terrified him on such a
primal level, like the way our lizard brain
reacts to some ancient apex predator.
And whatever this thing was, it clearly knew
something about him.
How else could it stage all these photos?
Joe got out of bed and looked out the window,
down onto his dark front street.
Empty, thankfully, but after this surprise
nightmare, he wasn’t going to take any chances.
He grabbed a kitchen knife from downstairs
and placed it on his bedside cabinet, right
next to his phone, with 911 on speed dial.
Joe Lillis, a 43 year old man, slept with
the lights on that night for the first time
in over thirty years.
Sadly for him, the nightmare was just beginning.
The next morning, Joe woke up unharmed, but
he wasn’t pleased to see that he’d gotten
several more texts in his sleep.
There was one taken outside of the local insurance
company office where he worked.
The strange creature with the skull for a
face was looming around the corner, peering
at the camera with its lipless grin.
Like it was mocking him.
Another photo was taken at the local supermarket
where Joe did most of his grocery shopping.
The frame was centralized on the cereal aisle,
bordered on both sides by walls of garish
mascots, endlessly repeated.
Down at the far end of the aisle was a looming,
dark figure, with that cold, canine skull
where a human face should be.
There were a few more, but worst of all was
the last one.
It was taken at the cemetery.
In the foreground, a headstone, reading “Carol
Lillis - Beloved Wife and Daughter.”
Joe was horrified to see that skull-faced
beast was rising up behind his wife’s grave,
long, clawed fingers curling around the top
of the headstone.
That was the moment that Joe decided to go
to the police about all this, before things
got even more out of hand.
He called an Uber to get down to the station
- He certainly didn’t feel like going anywhere
near his regular bus stop after last night.
He showed the photos he’d been sent so far
to an officer posted at the station, and they
agreed that there was certainly something
strange about it.
While the behavior undeniably bordered on
harassment, it hadn’t yet delved into criminal
territory, so he would sadly be on his own
until then.
The best they could do was stay in touch and
keep abreast of any new developments.
The only sage advice they could give him was
not to delete the photos, as they could always
be used as evidence in court later if things
escalated.
This was literally the last result that Joe
wanted out of this.
Considering how bizarre and threatening things
were getting already, he really didn’t want
to find out what escalation looked like in
this case.
But what else could he do but carry on, just
trying to exercise as much caution as he could
in these strange new circumstances?
He went to work and tried his best to stay
productive, despite the fact that every three
or so hours, a new photo would arrive.
Places that he liked to sit in the local parks,
stores he’d frequent, restaurants he liked
to eat at.
That nightmare skeleton dog thing would be
standing in all of them, just mugging for
the camera.
On one hand, every time he looked at one of
the photos, Joe felt like he was giving this
freak exactly what they wanted.
On the other hand, how could he possibly look
away?
What if he missed something that could save
his life?
It carried on much like that until later in
the evening.
Joe may not have been a genius, but he was
no fool, either.
He’d seen too many of those seedy True Crime
documentaries about kidnapping to take his
normal route home.
He took a real detour, frequently checking
over his shoulder the entire time.
Much to his relief, he didn’t see anything
out of place.
Good.
When he got home, he locked every door and
bolted every window.
Nothing would be getting the jump on him tonight.
That’s when the next picture came in: A
photograph of Joe’s empty office cubicle,
with the bony face of the creature looming
over the divider with a grin.
He could feel his heart pounding away in his
chest just looking at it.
How did this thing get around like this?
How was it able to infiltrate everywhere in
his entire goddamn life?
Suddenly, he felt a smile spreading across
his face.
This freak had just messed up, big time.
Before, all these creepy photos had been taken
in public places.
But the one taken in his office?
Oh, this crossed the line into trespassing.
The police would have to do something about
it now.
It’d given him an ace up his sleeve.
That confidence faded a few hours later when
he received another photo: This time, it was
the skull-faced monster just standing on the
sidewalk - The sidewalk that Joe remembered
walking on his “covert” alternative route.
He felt himself break into a cold sweat.
It seemed, whoever this was, he really did
hold no secrets from them.
Now more than ever, Joe didn’t feel safe
in his own home.
So you can only imagine how he felt when,
a few hours later, he received a photo of
the skull-faced stalker standing right outside
his own front door, staring into the camera.
It sent him rushing to the window again to
check outside, but of course, nobody was there.
The next day, when he called the police and
updated them on the situation, they told him
that they were doing all they could.
The best thing he could possibly do was to
remain calm, but vigilant.
He needed to keep an eye on the photos being
sent to him, so he could notify them if ever
he was in any immediate danger.
This put poor Joe’s paranoia at a fever
pitch.
Even when he went to work,
surrounded by coworkers,
by witnesses, he could scarcely tear his eyes
away from his phone.
He was a slave to the photos, forever waiting
for the next one.
Only to experience crushing regret when that
photo actually arrived.
It looked like it was taken moments before
it was sent to him.
Joe saw himself, looking at his own phone
in his office cubicle, with that huge, skull-faced
figure looming behind him.
He screamed out loud upon seeing it, and turned
to see if anything was behind him.
But of course, there was nothing there.
The police inspected the office, talked to
potential witnesses, and analyzed the photo.
It showed no signs of any
photographic manipulation,
but there were also no witnesses around the
office who claimed to see anything strange
that day.
There was also no security camera footage
in the last several days that showed this
figure coming in or out.
Joe Lillis started to feel like he was going
insane, and perhaps he was, but that didn’t
change the tangible and ever-present feeling
that he was in great danger.
He didn’t come into work the next day.
He’d received more photos like that in the
night: Of himself, taken in real time, with
that skull-faced freak looming.
He didn’t want to leave the house.
He didn’t want to go anywhere anymore.
He just didn’t feel safe out there.
How could he, with all this madness unfolding?
There was a time when he could have said something
like, “At least it only seems confined to
my phone”, he might’ve even suspected
that it had something to do with that strange
MalO app he downloaded a few days prior that
hadn’t seemed to do anything.
But the situation had evolved since then.
He wasn’t just seeing the creature in photos
anymore.
It was here.
He kept seeing quick flashes of it on the
other side of windows.
In reflections.
In the corner of his eyes, always darting
away if ever he turned towards it.
It was everywhere and nowhere.
It was here for him.
He just knew it.
The police couldn’t help.
Nobody could help.
Joe just sat in the corner of his bedroom,
clutching his kitchen knife, afraid to close
his eyes.
It could be anywhere.
It could be anywhere…
We know one thing for sure: Joe Lillis never
felt truly alone ever again.
He always had his new friend, waiting, just
out of sight.
And if ever you’re feeling lonesome, and
decide to download Mal0 version 1.0.0 yourself,
then you’ll never feel lonely again, either…
It was November 3rd, 1991 and Blake Newsom
loved his job.
He had a passion for organization, an undying
love of American political history, and was
a life-long member of the Republican party.
That’s why he took great pride in his position
as a filing clerk at the
Ronald Reagan Presidential
Library.
Or at least, he did, until his horrifying
encounter with SCP – 1981.
The worst day of Blake’s life began like
any other.
He was taking inventory of the archive’s
wide array of Betamax tapes, and making sure
they were all arranged carefully and conformed
with the filing system.
One by one, he checked footage of speeches
and addresses off of his list, until he came
upon a strange tape that had no business being
there.
The tape looked to be completely normal, but
it hadn’t been recorded on the archive inventory.
And there was something else off about it.
A single white sticker was on the front of
the tape with “RONALD REGAN CUT UP WHILE
TALKING" scrawled hastily with what was probably
a felt-tipped marker.
Blake was shocked and appalled – they hadn’t
even spelled the President’s name correctly!
What poor Mr. Newsom didn’t know was that
he was about to see something so disturbing
that he’d look back on that misspelling
like it was a treasured childhood memory.
Standard policy for tapes like this would
be to review and catalogue, or even throw
it out if necessary.
Typically, a lowly filing clerk like Blake
would need to seek approval from his superiors,
but curiosity got the better of him.
He commandeered one of the library’s televisions
and Betamax cassette players, and started
watching the footage.
For the first minute or so nothing seemed
out of the ordinary, just the president standing
at a podium giving his iconic “Evil Empire”
speech to the National Association of Evangelicals
at Sheraton Twin Towers Hotel, Orlando, Florida,
on March 8th, 1983.
However, the second the tape hit the one minute
and ten seconds mark, something unnatural
began to occur.
President Reagan’s speech began to veer
off, as the topic of conversation shifted
from the importance of family values to the
exquisite taste of human flesh.
Blake was taken aback.
Surely, he was hearing things?
But the tape only got worse.
President Reagan began to divulge the fact
that he enjoyed the taste of young flesh the
best, particularly that of infants.
As Reagan began to go into detail about how
exactly one should best cook an infant if
you want to seal in the flavour, the crowd
erupted into modest applause.
Blake started to feel sick.
He’d remembered watching this speech, and
President Reagan had said nothing of the sort!
Things only got weirder as the President’s
cheek suddenly opened up into a long, bleeding
gash, as though someone had cut into his face
with an invisible knife.
As the speech continued, and Reagan’s words
became more nonsensical and incoherent, the
injuries got worse, too.
His face developed puncture wounds, like he
was being stabbed.
Skin in some areas rotted and peeled off.
Reagan showed no awareness of the horrifying
injuries that seemed to be occurring spontaneously
on his body.
This was a living nightmare!
The tape came to a merciful end 22 minutes
in, after President Reagan’s throat appeared
to be slashed open and his insane speech was
reduced to quiet gurgles.
It fizzled out into static shortly after,
and Blake politely retired to the bathroom
to throw up.
Was this some sick prank or tampering or camera
trickery, perhaps?
He didn’t know but that tape was disgusting,
and whoever was responsible had to be punished.
Newsom contacted the police, hoping obscenity
charges could be pressed against the creator
of the tape once they were found.
The tape was taken into evidence, and a low-level
police investigation into the possible culprits
began.
While the police officers who viewed the tape
reported nightmares in the weeks following,
the creator of the tape was never found.
The investigation truly came to an end when
a superior closed the case
and the tape disappeared
from the evidence locker.
This, as you probably could have guessed,
was the work of a field agent from The SCP
Foundation.
Amnestics were then used to erase the memories
of everyone unlucky enough to witness the
tape, including Blake Newsom, who could finally
rest easy and return to his filing work.
The anomalous tape was now in responsible
hands.
It was given the designation SCP – 1981,
and given the object class “Safe” due
to its easily controlled and self-contained
nature.
Proper research and testing was now able to
begin and while nothing about the construction
of the tape suggested anything inherently
anomalous, repeat viewings of the video made
it clear that this went far beyond mere doctored
footage of a Presidential speech.
Every single time the tape is played, both
the speech made and the injuries received
by President Reagan change.
The few rules the tape seems to always follow
are that Reagan never reacts to the injuries
he’s receiving, it always has the same beginning
and total runtime, and the speech is always
corrupted.
These speeches have been described as “mostly
incoherent, lacking any sort of underlying
thematic structure and largely being composed
of nonsensical anecdotes and parables”,
so not that dissimilar from a regular Reagan
speech, but the topics always turn incredibly
dark and have included torture, mutilation,
death, cannibalism, ritual sacrifice, genocide,
and more.
The range of injuries shown on President Reagan
in the videos have included, but are by no
means limited to, impalement, mutilation,
flaying, and some tortures so gruesome that
the details have been redacted from official
files.
On several occasions, the details of President
Reagan’s speech have also eerily predicted
the future.
These include successfully predicting the
September 11th attacks in 2001 and the outcome
of the 2008 Russian presidential election.
Incidentally, this isn’t
even the only Reagan-related
SCP to predict the future.
No, there’s another entry in this incredibly
specific niche: SCP – 095, a highly degraded
copy of a comic known as “The Atomic Adventures
of Ronnie Ray-Gun.”
The title character bears a striking resemblance
to President Reagan, despite the fact that
the comic is confirmed by Foundation tests
to have been written in the early 1930s.
The comic is set in the far-off future world
of the 1980s, and follows a number of Ronnie’s
exploits in three stories.
The first, titled “Ronnie vs. Space Admiral
Carter”, seems to perfectly describe the
events of the 1980 presidential election.
The second, “Space Assassin!”, mirrors
the attempted assassination of President Reagan
by John Hinckley Jr.
And the third, titled “Jungle Planet!”,
retells the Iran-Contra controversies of 1986.
These comics were produced under the mysterious
and apparently non-existent company, “Future
Funnies.”
The Foundation hopes to track down the other
comics from this company whenever possible,
but they’ve had no luck on that front.
For now, there’s only SCP – 095.
During initial testing, Foundation staff watched
the tape frequently in case this strange,
corrupted version of President Reagan had
any other valuable predictions for the future.
However, during one of these screenings, one
of the D-Class observation personnel pointed
and yelled at the screen in horror.
Upon further examination of recorded footage,
researchers could see exactly what had concerned
the D-Class observer so much.
While, in other viewings of the tape, President
Reagan’s press detail had appeared totally
normal, in this one something was clearly
amiss.
Standing among the other dull, suit-wearing
political aides was a tall figure dressed
in a midnight-black cloak with a large, conical
hood obscuring his face.
The figure didn’t appear to move in the
footage – it just stood there, menacingly.
A later survey indicated that this figure
would appear in roughly one in seven viewings
of the tape.
This cloaked figure was designated SCP – 1981
– 1, and he became part of the recurring
imagery in the nightmares that often followed
a viewing of SCP – 1981.
Naturally, despite containment and preservation
attempts, the Foundation was aware that just
like any normal tape,
natural magnetic interference
would eventually degrade it beyond use.
Attempts to copy the footage onto another
Betamax tape failed to reproduce the anomalous
effects.
That’s why the Foundation has painstakingly
recorded any video and audio they could via
a standard commercial camcorder.
In one particularly terrifying playback, SCP
– 1981 – 1 took the president’s place
at the podium, staring directly into the camera.
The words “I SEE YOU” appeared over a
black screen shortly after.
Staff members were ordered never to make an
attempt at communicating with the figure,
and instead contact a Level 4 superior if
such an event occurs during a playback again.
The frightening and unfortunate effects of
SCP – 1981 would come to their logical conclusion
under the watchful eye of Dr. James Kyle Robinson,
Managing Archivist of Inert Safe-Class Objects
and Anomalous Items at Site 73.
He was contacted by Special Agent Arnold Rodriguez
and Special Agent Ethan Tate, members of secret
service with a duty of care to President Reagan.
Word had gotten to Reagan that there was an
anomalous artefact in the possession of the
Foundation that directly pertained to him,
and he wanted to see it.
Dr. Robinson obtained files and transcripts
pertaining to SCP – 1981 and handed them
over to the Agents, but refused to allow President
Reagan to see the tape directly without approval
from O5 Command.
But Reagan and the agents were persistent.
Eventually, O5 Command ordered a private screening
of the tape for President Reagan at the Sanford
Chemical Processing Plant – a front business
owned and operated by the Foundation for Amnestic
production.
Dr. Robinson offered President Reagan the
use of Amnestics after the session completed,
but Reagan declined.
The screening took place in Conference Room
B, and the tape was re-played three times.
It was on the third playback that things took
an interesting turn.
As the mutilated Reagan on the screen began
to rant about drinking the blood of a child
from the skull of Vladimir Putin, Reagan began
to silently mouth along to the words, as though
he remembered them.
He spoke about beings known as “The Destroyers”,
and potential apocalyptic events to come.
After the screening, Reagan once again refused
the offer of Amnestics, and departed.
It seemed as though all was well, until a
violent break-in at the
Sanford Chemical Processing
Plant that left the night guard dead.
A large number of Amnestics had been stolen
during the break-in, and security footage
showed that Agents Tate and Rodriguez had
been responsible.
The two agents were tracked down and traced
to the residence of Ronald Reagan, where the
Foundation came upon a disturbing sight: The
agents had pillaged large quantities of Class
A and B Amnestics and supplied them to President
Reagan, who – at some point after observing
SCP – 1981 – had been driven into a dangerous
madness.
The two agents wanted to cure him before he
caused harm to himself or others, but their
bungling had come with severe consequences.
Misapplying such a high quantity of Amnestics
had essentially destroyed Reagan’s mind,
and while the Foundation was able to stabilize
his condition, his impaired memory and cognitive
function would leave him unable to care for
himself independently.
In order to cover up for this grievous mistake,
a cover story was concocted about Reagan falling
victim to Alzheimer’s and facing severe
cognitive decline as a result.
Both Agents Tate and Rodriguez were fired
for their actions, had their memories wiped
by the Foundation, and were
assigned new identities.
Dr. Robinson, for his part in the disaster,
had to face a Foundation Ethics Committee
Disciplinary Hearing.
While SCP – 1981 continues to be classified
as“Safe” due to its unlikeliness to ever
breach containment, when you consider the
havoc it wrought on the mind of its singular
target, “safe” is hardly the word that
comes to mind.
It’s enough to make you wonder what other
tapes are lurking out there, just waiting
to be found
It all started with a panicked phone call.
A local landlady who owned a downtown tenement
building had called the police in hysterics.
Something horrifying had happened to one of
her tenants; she couldn’t possibly explain.
The one detail she was able to articulate
was that his room “looked like a rainforest.”
A police response team was on the case in no
time. They drove down to the tenement building,
met the crying landlady at the door, and found
their way to the room that’d caused all this
confusion. When they opened the door, they
saw with horror that she was right - trees,
plants, fungi, and even insects and animals were
all over the room. It was teeming with life.
The flora and fauna in this room
didn’t look like anything else
on Earth. And given the anomalous
nature of what had happened here,
it’s extremely possible they were right. The
tenant - a university professor who’d recently
gone on an anthropological expedition to the
Amazon rainforest - was nowhere to be seen.
But one of the officers spotted a grim
clue for what may have happened to him.
A large colony of anomalous mold was
quickly growing on the far wall. The
officer swore it was a trick of the
mind at first, but he was wrong. A
human skull was sinking into the tissue
of the mold, and to make matters worse,
whipping tendrils began to slither from the
empty eye sockets reaching for the new meat.
Thankfully, for everyone who was still alive at
this point, the SCP Foundation swooped in and
took over the situation with the help of a Mobile
Task Force and some containment specialists. The
landlady, the cops, and the other residents of
the building were given amnestics and relocated.
The building was purchased by the Foundation and
condemned while they searched the anomalous room
for the source of this unchecked biological
growth. And they found their answer in a most
unlikely form: An unmarked cassette tape,
still inside the player when they arrived.
The recording on this cassette tape
came to be known as SCP-407. It may seem
unassuming when compared to immortal, misanthropic
lizard-monsters and multi-dimensional chaos gods,
but the tape in that room, if it fell into
the wrong hands, could cause a mass ecological
catastrophe that would inevitably bloom into
a dreaded XK-Class End of the World Scenario.
So, first thing’s first: What’s actually on this
tape? Thanks to brief samples heard in tests with
D-Class Personnel, The Foundation was able to
discover that it was an approximately 28 minute
long recording of a song. It’s performed
in an unknown language, and appears to be
sung acapella style by a group of unknown
individuals. Fearing potential degradation
of the cassette tape, the Foundation backed it up
as an audio file in the Site 19 Computer Database.
Those who’ve been able to listen to the song
during testing have had an overwhelmingly
positive emotional response - describing it
as 'soothing', 'glorious', and 'beautiful'.
And for the first minute of its runtime,
the song’s anomalous effects really live up
to this reputation. When the song is played,
it massively accelerates cell growth within
its auditory range. Its potency is increased
by the volume and the length it’s allowed to
play. It’s important to note that plugging or
covering your ears won’t make any difference.
The area of effect seems to be defined by how
far the sound vibrations travel, and whether
you’re actually able to hear it is irrelevant.
But if you’re only listening for a minute or less,
you’ll be glad to feel the anomalous effects of
being within SCP-407’s auditory range. During
this specific period of time, it’s been shown to
be a kind of miracle-cure to almost all physical
maladies, with the exception of cancer. Thanks to
the cell growing and rejuvenating properties of
the song, the Foundation discovered that 407 was
an effective treatment for Alzheimer's disease,
Crohn's disease, brain and spinal cord injuries,
and normally fatal infections or wounds,
amongst other maladies. It was like a
version of SCP-500 - the pills that cure
everything - but one that would never run out.
So, if it’s such an effective healer, why wasn’t
it more widely employed by the Foundation?
Because of what happens if you keep listening.
If the song was played for two to three minutes,
the subject would begin to experience unnecessary
and unchecked cell growth - particularly on
the skin. The result would mostly be benign
tumors and calcium and fat deposits, which
though sometimes painful and disfiguring,
are not life threatening. At minute
four, single celled organisms in
the auditory vicinity of the song begin to
experience accelerated mitosis, also known
as cell division. This results in bacterial and
fungal growth that becomes extremely dangerous
for anyone and anything exposed. And beyond
minute five, things become truly monstrous.
The Foundation only ever conducted two tests
wherein the song was fully played. These tests
presented such a huge danger that further
testing of 407 was forbidden without explicit
permission from a member of O5 Command.
The first test involved a female member
of D-Class Personnel in a soundproofed but
unsterilized testing chamber. As expected,
she was initially delighted by the music. It
cured her injured knee and brought her back
to a state of peak physical fitness. But
this didn’t last for long. She soon began
to report intense dizziness and stomach pain,
resulting in severe sickness. At this point,
anomalous plant growth began in the corners of
the testing chamber. It seemed as though a whole
ecosystem was coming to life and evolving
at an impossible fast rate in the chamber.
Over the next few minutes, the D-Class experienced
a nightmarish physical transformation. Her skin
became a thick, callused mass. She
soon devolved further into a thick,
immobile blob of pure flesh, unrecognizable as
anything human while the chamber around her was
becoming a lush rainforest of alien plants.
These plants grew around and eventually on
her until there was nothing left. Shortly
after, all the plants died and decomposed,
giving away to a huge mound of anomalous
mold devouring the resulting mulch.
The mold itself began to evolve, growing large
mouth and hand-like structures that it used to
feed itself on the surrounding flora and fauna
as it began to grow back. When the song ended,
the Foundation brought the test to
a close, sterilized the room and
collected some samples for later. There was
nothing left of the original D-Class subject.
The second test wasn’t any nicer. While
at first, the subject - this time a male
member of D-Class personnel - appeared to become
more youthful and even gain an inch of height,
as the minutes passed, he began to experience
extreme discomfort. He soon began to vomit - with
the vomit quickly blooming into plants.
Plant shoots also began to quickly spring
out of his eyes and mouth, until his entire
body was destroyed by what appeared to be a
banana tree suddenly growing out of it.
Once again, the testing chamber became
a whole ecosystem - this one filled with
unique, never before seen mammals. However,
it all came to an end when the room was taken over
by a fast-growing, parasitic fungus that consumed
everything else with its spores and fungal
stalks. And it looked like it was breathing.
There was something concerning about both of
these tests - beyond the obvious physical horror
of watching death-by-unchecked-cell-growth. What
was this mysterious fungus that kept appearing,
and seemed to take over everything it
touched in the end? The Foundation tested
the samples it collected rigorously,
and came to a surprising conclusion:
They’d actually encountered this same
fungus before, but not in this dimension.
SCP-507 is a man with dimension-hopping abilities.
The one problem is, he can’t control where and
when he hops. As a result, he’s been stuck
in a number of scary alternate dimensions,
but one seemed eerily similar to what the
Foundation was encountering with SCP-407. In one
dimension he briefly hopped into, 507 encountered
an abandoned version of Site 19, strewn with
corpses covered in that same breathing mold. He
was horrified, but decided to inspect further,
hoping to find his way out of the facility and
discover some answers about what happened here.
However, when he found his way out, what he
discovered didn’t comfort him. The entire
world seemed to be covered by this same mold.
There was nothing left. It’d consumed everything.
Thanks to Foundation tests, both molds
were found to be similar to the Cordyceps
Fungi - a kind of dangerous, parasitic
mold. Except this one appeared to be a
far more evolved and even more deadly
version of the fungus. What could this
mean? What was the origin of this
anomalous song? Would it and the
fungus it seems to inspire someday destroy
the world as we know it, and kill us all?
We’ll never actually know the answer to any of
this, and it’s thanks to an extremely unlikely
ally: A Person of Interest nicknamed L.S.,
a prominent member of The Serpent’s Hand.
This enigmatic figure had previously come into
possession of SCP-268 - a hat that made them
almost impossible to detect. With the help of this
hat, L.S. breached Site 19 in an incident that
was later dubbed Security Breach Incident X23.
While it’s believed that L.S. mainly broke into
the facility to make use of SCP-914, they
performed a curious action along the way:
They hacked into the Foundation database,
and deleted all traces of SCP-407,
effectively neutralizing it.
In a note left by L.S., they said “You’ll
thank me for deleting what you call ‘407’.”
Why would a member of The Serpent’s
Hand, a Group of Interest that is often
militant in their anti-neutralization
stance, neutralize an SCP themselves?
The answer to this lays in who exactly L.S.
Is. This mysterious figure isn’t technically
one person - they’re a group of the same
person, namely a woman named Alison Chao,
from a number of different dimensions.
They meet in the Wanderer’s Library,
the headquarters of The Serpent’s Hand that exists
between dimensions, to coordinate their missions.
Why does this matter in regards to SCP-407?
Because the nature of L.S. allows them to
know what’s going on in a huge number
of dimensions at once. This means,
much like the brief glimpse given by SCP-507,
L.S. likely knows about another universe where
407 and its horrific mold has already caused
an XK - Class Scenario and destroyed the world.
And if it happened there due to poor
biological containment measures or 407
falling into the wrong hands, it could happen
here too. Unless, of course, someone stepped
in and dealt with the problem personally. And
while the Foundation’s policy is typically to
contain rather than neutralize the anomalies
they find, we have to admit, we’re probably
with the Serpent’s Hand on this one. Some songs,
as it turns out, are just better left unplayed...
You’re sitting in the middle of a cheering
crowd.
The arena around you is electric, fans hollering
from their seats as they watch the basketball
game.
Every point scored, every shot missed, and
every skillful pass of the ball sends waves
of excitement over everyone in the audience.
Applause, shouts, and chants fill the air.
It distracts you for a moment, you find yourself
swept up in the energy of the game.
But slowly, surely, a nagging feeling creeps
up on you as your eyes follow the ball.
That feeling turns to a sickening realization
as one of the players jumps and dunks the
basketball, scoring another two points.
You notice the look on his face, the same
look on the faces of all the other players
on the court: a solemn, hopeless expression.
It’s the same look of silent despair worn
by all the spectators around you.
Then you remember, you’ve watched this exact
game of basketball before.
Many, many times before.
And that is when you feel the same hopeless
expression appear on your own face, realizing
just how long you have been here, watching
this game over and over.
Reminded that you will never, ever leave this
arena.
Welcome to SCP-1733.
To the untrained eye, SCP-1733 seems to be
a completely harmless item.
Stored in a digital video recorder, it is
kept secure in the dusty depths of the SCP
Foundation’s video archives.
If any researcher is given permission to study
SCP-1733, they will find it to be an ordinary
VHS tape.
But what about the contents of said tape?
Does it contain a bizarre, disconnected series
of black and white video clips that when viewed
only give the watcher seven days before the
spirit of a drowned girl comes crawling out
their TV screen to kill them?
Well, not exactly, but we’re sure that if
such a tape exists, the Foundation probably
has it under lock and key too.
The footage on SCP-1733 is as seemingly banal
as the ordinary VHS tape itself.
When played, the viewer will witness a TV
broadcast of a basketball game.
Specifically, the 2010-2011 NBA season opener,
broadcast on television and captured on tape
by an unknown civilian.
The game took place on the 26th of October
2010 in the TD Garden arena
in Boston, Massachusetts,
a game where the hometown Boston Celtics took
on the Miami Heat.
By now, perhaps you are wondering what is
so special about this particular game, and
why the SCP Foundation would be so interested
in keeping a VHS recording of it so secure.
Is one of the O5 Council secretly a Celtics
fan?
While that’s impossible to say for sure,
what we do know for certain is that SCP-1733
is far more than just a harmless recording
of a basketball game.
The SCP Foundation first caught wind of SCP-1733’s
existence the day after the game.
On October 27th, a Boston native that had
watched and recorded the game made comments
on social media about a technical foul that
the game’s referee had failed to pick up
on.
According to this individual, during the third
quarter, an instance of unsportsmanlike conduct
took place between Ray Allen and Chris Bosh.
The person making these claims was quickly
ridiculed by commenters on the same thread.
But then this person uploaded a clip of this
foul from the footage they had recorded.
The other commenters were dumbfounded.
During the original broadcast, that foul had
never happened, but the recording showed it
clear as day.
The footage was quickly expunged and all traces
of the clip removed from the Internet by personnel
acting on behalf of the SCP Foundation.
Any that had viewed the video on Facebook,
or been a part of the comments debating this
previously non-existent foul, were tracked
down via their IP addresses.
All of them, including the owner of the tape,
were given amnestics to wipe their memories
of the supposed infraction, and SCP-1733 was
returned to the Foundation for further analysis.
Researchers at the Foundation were determined
to understand the anomalous nature of SCP-1733,
and why the footage contained on this particular
VHS tape was so different from the basketball
game’s original broadcast.
At first, the differences in the game seemed
to be only slight changes from the one that
actually aired on TV; a different foul here,
a small point difference there.
While the recording of the game contained
on SCP-1733 was slightly different from the
real-life game, perhaps even more interesting
was that these differences changed with repeat
viewings.
Researchers wouldn’t observe the same differences
every time they watched SCP-1733, but would
instead spot something different that had
been changed each time they restarted the
tape.
And as they continued to watch and rewatch
SCP-1733’s footage, the true horror of the
video’s anomalous properties became more
and more apparent.
As the footage recorded on SCP-1733 began
to diverge more and more from the original
broadcast, researchers shifted their attention
away from the basketball game itself and onto
the people watching it.
Just like the specifics of the game itself,
the fans in the arena seemed to also change
with every re-watch of the tape.
And even stranger, the people in the crowd
seemed to not only be aware of their existence
within the footage, but also retained memories
of every previous replayed version.
Each time the researchers had watched SCP-1733,
the audience trapped within had gained more
and more cognizance.
Every man, woman, and child in the audience
of that basketball game began remembering
that they had seen multiple variations of
the same game over and over again.
This first became apparent
to Foundation researchers
when the game’s commentators, two presenters
named Mike and Tommy, began to comment on
a strange sense of ‘déjà vu’ they were
experiencing as they watched the Boston Celtics
and Miami Heat playing.
Both seemed to share the notion that the game
they were witnessing was strangely familiar,
and in later replays of the tape, these two
commentator personalities were able to recall
the events of the game with perfect, vivid
accuracy.
While they never address the viewer directly,
this cumulative effect seems to have extended
to every person that was present within the
arena at the time that the original broadcast
was recorded.
Everyone from the commentators to the coaches,
the players to the patrons, all remember the
diverging versions of the basketball game,
but seem to have no awareness that they are
trapped inside a recording on a VHS tape.
It should be noted that it is still unclear
whether the entities are real people, or digital
copies that solely reside on the tape.
Every individual shown to be inside TD Garden
on the 26th of October 2010, seems to be identical
to their counterparts in the real world.
Each of the basketball players on both the
Boston Celtics and Miami Heat teams have the
exact same level of talent as they do in reality,
and their individual mannerisms are perfectly
recreated in the SCP-1733 footage.
And the same true of the fans in the audience,
each one appearing to be, in every conceivable
way, a living human being.
But the most unnerving aspect of SCP-1733
was found when Foundation agents were tasked
with tracking down the members of the audience
who were seen on the tape and they found…
nothing.
Unlike the players and coaches who can quite
easily be found in our world, with many of
them still playing or involved with professional
basketball, personnel were unable to find
a single trace of any of the people from the
audience.
Not one clue as to their current whereabouts
or status.
It is unclear how, but it appears that everyone
shown on SCP-1733, especially those watching
the game unfold from the stands, is a person
trapped in digital form, stuck watching variations
of the same match on a loop.
Researchers at the SCP Foundation who were
studying SCP-1733 initially theorized that
the tape had been designed to display an infinite
variety of different game outcomes.
Given that the tactics utilized by the players
were different with each playback of SCP-1733,
this seemed to be the case, that the tape
was showing a ‘what if’ scenario each
time the tape was rewound and played from
the start.
But the scenario wasn’t resetting each time.
It was clear they were learning.
By the 34th replay of the footage, the Boston
Celtics and Miami Heat were so in-tune with
the opposing team’s playbook that both sides’
players were able to perfectly and precisely
counter their opponents’ moves, and kept
the score at zero to zero for much of the
game.
At this stage in the Foundation’s research,
the players on the SCP-1733 tape had not yet
become fully aware that they had played the
same game already in earlier playbacks, but
it is possible that weak memories of the earlier
versions of the same match
manifested as instinctive
ways players could counter the moves of their
rival team.
However, by the time Foundation researchers
had replayed the SCP-1733 footage 45 times,
the players, their coaches and fans watching
the game had become aware of what was happening
to them.
It was at this point that the digital recording
from TD Garden changed dramatically.
Realizing that they’d been playing the same
game of basketball over and over, the players
refused to participate any longer.
Everyone in attendance began to attempt escape
from the tape where they’d been unknowingly
imprisoned.
But not a single one of the stadium’s doors
would budge, and neither the fans, nor the
players, seemed to be able to leave through
any other exit out of TD Garden.
Over the following playbacks of the SCP-1733
video tape, attempts at escape grew increasingly
daring.
In one playback, a full-scale riot broke out.
In another, makeshift explosives were built
and used by those trapped to try and blast
their way to freedom.
As their cognition grew and they began to
remember friends and family from outside the
video tape, the crowd trapped in SCP-1733
grew even more desperate.
Players and their coaches retired to locker
rooms, withdrawing from the crowd for a time.
The rest of the people in the footage began
to form factions amongst themselves, one of
the more prominent calling themselves the
“Faithkeepers”.
These individuals voiced their belief that
they had been confined to TD Garden as some
form of spiritual punishment, as a result
of the consumerism that is
rife in a post-industrial
society.
The Faithkeepers began burning offerings in
the center of the basketball court, phones,
wallets, car keys, anything that reminded
them of the modern world.
Over the subsequent playbacks of SCP-1733,
the Faithkeepers grew in
their numbers, indoctrinating
more of the crowd into their movement.
Those still trying to escape from the stadium
were causing more damage to themselves than
their enclosure, with three men caught in
the blast of another crude bomb placed on
an exit door.
Unfortunately for them, the door barely showed
a scratch in the aftermath of the detonation.
As Foundation researchers continued replaying
the tape, those trapped within SCP-1733 descended
into depraved acts, and incidences of violence
became rampant.
Some even attempted to take their own lives
in acts of desperation, jumping from balconies
in the hopes of ending the loop.
Those that had joined the growing ranks of
the Faithkeepers did not engage in such behavior,
instead creating makeshift curtains to separate
themselves from the breakdown that was taking
place among the others trapped within the
SCP-1733 tape.
At some point beyond the 112th playback of
the video tape, the
Faithkeepers marched off-screen
and brought the basketball teams back out
to the main court.
They then began a ritualistic
sacrifice, disemboweling
the professional athletes for their fellow
prisoners to see.
This had no noticeable effect, with the recording
of the game resetting as it had done in earlier
re-watched.
In a later playback, the Faithkeepers then
began to call for all the children in the
stadium to be sacrificed in the same way.
Testing on SCP-1733 was finally suspended
indefinitely after this point, and as far
as we know, the crowd remains trapped inside
the anomalous recording of this particular
Celtics Heat basketball game.
Foundation researchers have been unable to
produce the same anomalous effects as those
of SCP-1733, even when using the DVR that
original produced the recording.
The digital video recorder itself does not
seem to imprint the same properties onto other
VHS tapes, making SCP-1733 an isolated anomaly.
However, the next time you find yourself at
a basketball game, it might be worth asking
yourself: Have I seen this game before?
Do you like scary movies?
If you’re a fan of horror, there have probably
been quite a few times where you’ve found
yourself yelling at the movie screen: “Don’t
go up to the attic!”
“Don’t split up!”
“Don’t check out the noise in the basement,
run out the front door!”
You know the characters can’t hear you,
but when the story is engaging enough to make
you care about their well-being, you can’t
help but try and give them a hand.
After all, you’d want someone to save you
from a machete-wielding maniac stalking through
the summer camp you took up your new counselor
job at.
If someone was watching you hide in the closet,
listening for a masked killer’s footsteps
with a kitchen knife in your hand, you’d
want them to give you a heads up when the
killer was getting ready to chop through the
door with an axe!
Of course, the characters in your favorite
movies never listen.
Because, you know, that’s how movies work.
But in 1985, a young man returned a VHS tape
entitled “Return of the Suburb Slasher”
to his local video store
with a peculiar complaint:
the main character of the movie stopped mid-action
to look at the camera, and beg for his help.
The video store clerk laughed him off, and
refused to give him a refund - though he did
eventually give in and offer store credit
after the man began to cry.
He decided to take the tape home and watch
it, just to see what all the fuss was about.
After all, he’d never seen someone cry at
a horror movie like that.
So he sat down on his favorite beanbag chair,
pushed the tape into the VCR, and pressed
play.
Apparently his shell-shocked customer had
at least remembered to be kind and rewind.
The movie told the story of Heather Campbell,
a young woman planning to host a party at
her family’s home in a classic suburban
cul-de-sac while her parents are out of town.
In equally classic slasher fashion, this party
would take place on the 10th anniversary of
a series of grisly murders
in the same neighborhood,
committed by the mysterious Suburb Slasher.
As the party kicks off with loud music, teenage
debauchery, and lots of drinking out of red
plastic cups, the killer appears to pick off
the group of friends one by one.
Like other classic slasher villains, your
Michael’s and your Jason’s, the Suburb
Slasher also covers their face, wearing a
black burlap sack over their head that masks
all identifiable features.
The first 90 minutes of the movie were fun,
but basic.
A canoodling couple gets decapitated here,
an unnecessary shower scene is cut short by
a stabbing there, the sort of thing you’d
expect.
But at about 97 minutes in, something impossible
happened.
Heather walked into the living room, finding
her friends’ dead bodies strewn across it,
and let out a scream that measured up to the
bests in the genre.
The teen scream queen then began to run, as
the killer appeared to chase her.
She made her way into the basement of the
house, locking the door behind her.
Then, she turned to the camera, tears in her
eyes, shirt spattered with blood, and said:
“Hey Mister, I don’t know you, and I don’t
know why you’ve just sat there watching
this without doing nothing, but please.
I’m begging you, help me out here.
What can I do to survive this?”
At first, the clerk thought he was under the
influence of some mind-altering substance,
but the only things in his system were popcorn
and store-brand soda.
No, this was really happening.
He stared, open-mouthed, at the screen, where
Heather watched him expectantly.
He was too stunned to speak.
After a moment of silence, Heather sighed
dejectedly, shaking her head, and turned back
toward the stairs.
She slowly walked back to the basement door,
unlocked it, and pulled it open.
There, the killer was waiting
with his expressionless
burlap mask.
The clerk’s eyes widened, and he cried out
“No!”
but it was too late.
The film suddenly cut to black, and with a
whirring sound, the VCR spat the tape back
out.
The clerk sat there, staring at the tape.
What could he do with it?
Should he make a copy, send it to someone
else and pass the curse along?
Should he try to watch it again?
He wasn’t sure he could bear to see Heather
looking at him with those same pleading eyes.
Then, he remembered an ad he had seen in the
back of his favorite comic book: “Seen something
you can’t explain?
A brush with the unknown keeping you up at
night?
We’re looking for stories of the strange
and unusual!
Write to us now!”
Maybe they could do something that he couldn’t.
He put the tape back into its cover, placed
it in an envelope, and mailed it off the next
day.
A few days later, the package reached its
intended recipient: an undercover branch of
the SCP Foundation tracking anomalous activity
via a series of ads in comic books and video
stores to tap into one of the most underutilized
resources in the world: nerds.
The tape was designated SCP-5733, and Heather
and the masked killer were designated SCP-5733-2
and SCP-5733-1, respectively.
After an initial viewing confirmed its anomalous
properties, a research team headed by Dr.
Carpenter began to perform a series of tests.
Testing was open to all Foundation employees,
subject to approval by Dr. Carpenter.
Approved personnel would be placed in a Site
73 multipurpose room with a VHS player and
a television.
The staff member would then watch the movie,
and attempt to engage with Heather and help
her escape.
For the first test, D-Class 1973 was selected.
When Heather turned to the camera and asked
for help, he asked if she had a car.
When she confirmed that
yes, she did, he instructed
her to sneak back upstairs, find her car keys,
leave through the back door, and drive as
fast and as far away as possible.
She successfully retrieved the car keys, but,
when she reached the car, she saw that the
tires had been slashed.
Heather began to panic, but 1973 talked her
through it, telling her to smash the window
of a neighbor’s car and unlock the door.
She complied, and 1973 instructed her on how
to hot-wire the vehicle.
The car started, and with a triumphant laugh
she sped out of the cul-de-sac.
Just as her car began to pull away, the killer
emerged from the backseat, wielding a kitchen
knife.
Heather screamed, and the tape cut to black.
For the next test, D-Class 1944 was selected.
He began by telling Heather to find her father’s
shotgun, seen earlier in the film, and use
it to take out the killer before they could
get to her.
She snuck up to her parents’ room and found
the gun, only for the killer to appear in
the doorway behind her.
She aimed the gun and fired…but nothing
happened.
The killer opened their hand, dropping the
shotgun’s shells on the floor.
She was close, but the killer was one step
ahead.
She screamed as they approached with the knife,
and again, the tape cut to black.
After several tests were conducted with D-class
subjects, and no adverse effects were reported
- aside from the obvious trauma of failing
to save Heather’s life - testing was opened
up to all Foundation staff.
Assistant Researcher Felissa Baker volunteered.
She believed her extensive knowledge of the
slasher genre would give her the tools to
help Heather strategize.
After speaking with Heather about her skills,
which mainly included party
planning and babysitting,
Felissa determined that Heather should seek
outside help.
With Felissa’s help, Heather made her way
out of the house and over to the home of her
next door neighbor, Mr. Loomis.
When she got there, the door was open, and
the lights were off.
It didn’t look great, but she didn’t really
have much of a choice but to go inside.
She made her way to the bedroom, where Mr.
Loomis and his wife were lying in bed.
She tried to wake him, but the camera zoomed
in to reveal his throat had been slashed.
The shape in bed next to him sat up, and was
not in fact his wife, but the Suburb Slasher
instead.
As the figure raised their signature kitchen
knife, the screen went black.
SCP-5733 became a competition of sorts among
Foundation staff, each volunteer proposing
their knowledge would help them get Heather
to safety.
Assistant Researcher Nick Englund-Daskewisz
proposed telling Heather to call for help,
giving her a secret phone number for the SCP
Foundation circa 1983, the time in which the
movie was set.
However, when Heather reached the phone, it
had been destroyed, smashed into pieces.
Next to it was a note, written in blood, that
said: “The only Foundation here is FEAR.”
Then, the killer appeared behind Heather,
and the tape went black.
Somehow, the killer knew about the SCP Foundation.
Perhaps, in a manner of speaking, the call
was coming from inside the house.
Next, Field Agents Malcolm Pleasance and Donald
McDowell were selected due to their extensive
knowledge of hand-to-hand combat.
They attempted to teach Heather various fighting
and self-defense techniques, while she survived
on the limited supplies available in the basement.
She eventually left the basement, and, when
the killer appeared, began to fight them.
After twenty three minutes of combat, she
knocked the Slasher to the floor, and grabbed
a candlestick to finish them off.
As the agents watching began to celebrate,
a second version of the Suburban Slasher appeared
behind her, lunging forward.
Just before the new killer made contact, the
tape cut to black.
During this test, the Slasher seemed more
adept at combat than it had before, as though
it could hear the advice being given to Heather.
With other techniques failing, Field Agent
Tilda-Joan Bennett was brought in for a test,
selected due to her expertise in thaumaturgy.
She instructed Heather on basic offensive
and defensive thaumaturgy, before guiding
her out of the house and into the front yard.
When the Slasher appeared, brandishing their
knife, Heather was able to sign a protective
glyph and defend against the knife’s blow.
She followed this with a wind spell that pushed
the killer further away.
Heather began to run down the driveway, making
a break for survival, when the Slasher suddenly
performed a freeze spell that rendered her
unable to move.
Heather’s wide, panicked eyes stared down
the barrel of the camera in a silent scream
as the killer approached her, recovered knife
in hand, before the tape went black.
Eventually, Dr. Carpenter volunteered to conduct
a test.
He instructed his research team to prepare
a list of options for Heather’s survival,
divided into four categories: What to take
from the basement, where to go once leaving
the basement, how to exit the house, and how
to escape the cul-de-sac.
He was not informed about any of these options,
but rather had them printed out and placed
into plastic bowls on the day of the test.
There were also three cards created and placed
face-down, reading “Face,” “body”,
and “legs.”
When Heather addressed Dr. Carpenter, he informed
her that he would be randomly
selecting instructions
for her, and asked that she follow them exactly.
The first slip of paper instructed Heather
to grab a pair of garden shears from the basement,
and climb the stairs back into the main house.
Next, she was told to go upstairs to the bedroom,
then downstairs into the dining room.
She complied, and there was no sign of the
killer so far.
Third, Dr. Carpenter told Heather to run back
upstairs, out the bedroom window, onto the
roof, and then jump down into the garden.
Then, it was time for the next step.
He told Heather to jump over the fence into
the neighbor’s garden, and run down the
street until she could find help.
As Heather made her way down the road, the
Slasher broke through the front door of her
house, but did not chase after her.
Heather continued running down the road for
twenty minutes, as the trees and light began
to dwindle.
The surroundings began to grow darker and
darker, until they resembled a void.
Dr. Carpenter instructed her to keep walking.
She could make out lights and houses in the
distance.
She ran toward the neighborhood, but stopped
suddenly and began to panic.
She was back in her own neighborhood, in front
of her own house, and the killer was waiting
for her.
As Heather demanded to know what to do, Carpenter
flipped over one of the three cards.
It read, “face,” and so he told Heather
to attack the killer’s face with the shears.
Then, the killer’s legs.
Then, his body.
The killer dodged her attack, grabbed the
shears, and pushed her to the ground.
As Heather looked up at the killer, his face
could be seen through the torn sack…it was
Dr. Carpenter.
Heather screamed, and the tape cut to black.
Talk about a third-act twist.
The movie itself did not create the killer,
but somehow the viewer did, and it also made
the killer more creative.
After this incident, all testing on SCP-5733
was suspended, and attempts to help turn Heather
from victim to survivor were halted.
Searching for answers, the Foundation looked
into Crystal Elms Productions, the production
company listed on the video tape’s cover.
No record of the production company, the film,
or any of its cast could be found.
Several months after testing on SCP-5733 was
suspended, another tape was found.
Because let’s face it baby, these days,
you’ve gotta have a sequel.
The new tape was titled “The Suburb Slasher
Strikes Again,” and was purported to be
produced by Crystal Elms Productions in 1985.
It was designated SCP-6733.
Unlike its predecessor, this tape was only
tested once.
A member of D-class personnel was first shown
SCP-5733 up until the point where it became
anomalous, and was then shown SCP-6733.
He was left completely alone in order to watch
the contents of the tape.
The following was what was on it.
Dr. Malcolm Baines entered the testing chamber
to find D-1974, or Jaime, sitting across from
the television set.
He introduced himself, and ran a series of
cognitive tests.
He asked Jaime what he thought of the film,
and he said, “It was pretty much your standard
slasher film.
There's a group of teens who've just graduated
high school and go to a local camping site
by a lake to celebrate.
One of them mentions it's near the site where
the killer, The Slasher, was shot dead by
police a year prior after a rampage-”
Dr. Baines clarified, asking if this was a
reference to the first film.
Jaime continued, “It's not really clear.
They all think it's a joke, apart from the
main girl — she says her dad's a police
officer and she's seen video evidence of the
attack.
No-one references any of the characters from
the first film though, and they don't show
up in this one either.
The Slasher's the only constant.”
According to Jaime, the main events of the
film revolved around a lakeside camping trip
and quickly began to go wrong.
Dr. Baines inquired about the nature of the
Slasher’s kills, and Jaime elaborated, “He's
still got a kitchen knife, same weapon as
the first film, so he stabs a lot of them.
It's pretty gory for the time it was made.
He slashes up someone's face, then the nerdy
guy gets stabbed through the eye — that
one's pretty good, the camera gets sprayed
with blood.
One of the teens gets his head crushed wide
open.”
Dr. Baines asked Jaime how the scenes made
him feel, and he responded, “Like…
there's some good jump scares, and the tension's
fairly high at points, but it's a little dated.
I've seen scarier, but I've also seen worse
horrors.”
Only one part of the film stood out to him:
He described it: “So, the girl and her best
friend, the one that's been looking out for
her this whole time, enter into a cellar.
The Slasher creeps up from behind, and grabs
the friend — tears his head clean off his
neck.
The Slasher then chases the other teen to
the side of the lake.
He's advancing on her.
The camera's set on the water of the lake,
it's a wide shot.
You've got the lake waterline parallel to
the top and bottom of the shot, so it splits
the screen horizontally.
She's fallen over, crawling away from him.
As he advances on her, the camera zooms in
— slowly though.
It takes its time.
He does too.
There's music at the start of the scene: deep,
dark synths.
This stops as the camera moves closer though.
I forgot to say, it's, it's a long scene.
Longer than five minutes, maybe it was ten.
I don't know.
It felt longer than ten.
So the Slasher's approaching her, we're - the
viewers - approaching the shore.
Then the music stops, and it's just his footsteps
and her pleading.
And she's pleading man, she's… there's these
big, inhales of breath stifled by the mucus
running out her nose.
She's babbling, but it gets to a point she's
not even saying words, just making noise.”
As Jaime continued, he began to grow increasingly
distressed.
“The camera's real close to the shore now
— and the Slasher stops.
He turns his head and looks straight at the
camera.
You can't see his eyes, but you know he's
looking straight at you.
And he just stands there, staring.
Eventually the girl crawls out the frame,
or the camera zooms past her.
I can't remember which.
It just keeps zooming in on his face.
Where his face should be under the hood.
The girl keeps screaming off-camera.
Then there's this guttural, ripping noise
and the screaming stops.
It just stops, but the camera keeps moving.
You can see the individual droplets of blood
splashed across him.
You can see the fabrics that make up his hood.
His face soon takes up the entire shot.
And then… black.
No credits or nothing.
The tape just cuts to black, and was pushed
out the player.”
Dr. Baines pushed a bit, asking if there was
anything anomalous he could be forgetting.
then, Jaime thought of something.
“The girl.
Her friends.
All of them.
I don’t think they had names.”
Jaime became increasingly disturbed by the
film over time, calling Dr. Baines into his
dormitory to ask him if they had shown him
a snuff film.
After falling asleep, he had a vivid dream
of the lake, crawling alongside it, recalling
the deaths of his friends at the hand of a
masked killer.
When he woke up, he saw a shadow outside the
window of his room.
It stood there, silent and unmoving, all night.
It only vanished when the sun came up.
The next night, surveillance caught the image
of a humanoid shape running through the forest,
but the guards found no trace of it.
Dr. Baines returned to Jaime’s cell to find
him deeply distressed.
He repeated over and over that the Slasher
was coming for him.
Dr. Baines dismissed this concern.
Once Jaime was alone, he stared into the mirror
as the temperature began to drop.
“You’re here, aren’t you?”
He said.
A gloved hand punched through the mirror,
spraying glass everywhere.
On the other side, there he was: The Suburb
Slasher.
Jaime fled his dormitory and ran for his life,
as the Slasher followed him.
Security Officer Loren confronted the Slasher,
but they lifted him up by the neck and stabbed
the familiar kitchen knife through his head.
Jaime continued to make his way through the
facility, the Slasher following and leaving
a trail of destruction and bodies in his wake.
Then, he reached Dr. Baines, who was confused
by his behavior.
Dr. Baines insisted that the needed to get
to the basement, but, terrified, Jaime resisted
him.
The two men scuffled, and Jaime shoved Dr.
Baines hard, sending him careening into the
wall.
A lighting rig fell from the ceiling, landing
on Dr. Baines.
Several strangers ran into the room, calling
for a medic on-set, and asking for production
and lighting to come back and re-set everything.
Offscreen, a director yelled “Cut!”
The Slasher’s face appeared, taking up the
entirety of the camera, and the tape cut to
black.
This version of the tape’s events was created
after the tape was watched by D-1888 in a
testing session with Dr. Carpenter.
There has never been a Dr. Baines in the SCP
Foundation’s employ.
Somehow, this second tape creates a localized
destabilization of reality.
It is unknown how many times it has actually
been tested.
So be careful what horror rentals you decide
to watch.
You might just find yourself in the middle
of the action, and no matter what you think
you know about surviving a slasher film, there
will be no escape.
You can run, but you can’t hide.
“Okay, guys, so to wrap up this video, I
really don’t think this ‘cursed episode’
of this show was real.
It’s obviously just a really good scary
fan animation, and the fact the creators behind
it didn’t come out and claim ownership of
it sooner, allowing it to be reposted and
reuploaded so many times is really what got
people thinking it was legit.
That being said, it’s still a good attempt
at what a cursed, lost episode would look
like, so shout out to those animators, man!
“Anyway, I’ve been the G.O.A.T.
HellHolder98, be sure to like this video,
subscribe to my channel down below.
Hey, if you know about any more lost media
you want me to cover, leave it in the comments
and I’ll check it out.
Oh, and be sure to follow
my socials @HellHolder98,
I go live most days and post updates about
new videos on my story, so go check it out!
Alright, until then, I’ll see you somewhere
down the line!”
The moment his finger pushed the button to
stop the camera recording, the practiced,
false smile dropped from Holden’s face.
It was hard not to feel down after he’d
finished filming a new video, not thanks to
any post-creativity slump, but the more depressing
knowledge of just how much of an uphill battle
this whole thing was.
It felt like yesterday when Holden had first
gotten into the creepier side of the internet.
He never ventured into anything illicit or
outright illegal, mind you.
But there was a distinct corner of the web
that had pulled him in when he was still at
school, and just starting to spend more time
online.
This part of the internet was filled with
scary stories that were mostly fake or made
up for likes – but that could have been
real.
There were unsettling animations, short clips
that had been hand-drawn to give people the
creeps and keep them up at night.
Not to mention a whole archive of public safety
announcement videos, terrifying workplace
and road safety warnings that used to be broadcast
on TV, and were as petrifying that the most
acclaimed horror movies.
Speaking of things that were broadcast to
TV, that had gradually become Holden’s specialist
subject.
One of his friends had sent him the link to
a fictional account of someone who had supposedly
uncovered an unaired episode of a Saturday
morning kid’s cartoon – or so this person
claimed anyway.
They went on to describe bizarre imagery,
so intense and terrifying that it was unbefitting
of a show for children.
Then, the person who made the original post
explained how they got into contact with the
show’s creators via email, to ask them about
this cursed episode.
The showrunner responded stating that the
episode the poster had allegedly seen, didn’t
even exist.
To Holden, it didn’t matter if the story
was real or not.
That wasn’t the point.
What was far more important was that it felt
real.
To him, it was plausible, even possible, that
there were pieces of media out there in the
world that had never seen the light of day.
Episodes of TV shows or entire movies that
were so wild and out there that they could
have been banned and buried long before the
dawn of internet, wherein there was a record
of everything, and nothing was ever really
lost.
The idea of uncovering those lost pieces of
media became Holden’s primary hobby.
He’d come home from school, throw his backpack
onto his bed, and then sit in front of his
computer for hours without even changing out
of the clothes he had been wearing all day
in class.
But all time he spent trawling through forum
threads, following and messaging collectors
on social media, listening to theories, and
coming up with his own; eventually it began
to encroach on other things.
Much to his mom’s disappointment, Holden’s
grades took a rapid decline, and it wasn’t
long before he was failing his classes bad
enough to not make the cut to continue on
at school.
But, as much as it upset his mother, Holden
really didn’t mind.
He was already thinking way beyond high school
and knew he didn’t need grades to be able
to do the one thing he wanted to with his
life.
Holden set up his own channel with the plan
to start uploading videos under his new online
alter ego.
And before long, ‘HellHolder98’ was born.
He centered his whole internet persona around
lost media, discussing which popular rumors
were true and which were fictionalized for
likes and clicks.
It started out with a few discussion videos,
where he would simply sit in his bedroom,
a camcorder opposite him as he spoke.
But before long, Holden was adding more and
more flair to his content, learning how to
edit on his computer, adding clips or screenshots
he could find of supposed lost TV episodes
to give his videos some credibility; a very
necessary quality when trying to determine
if certain things were real or not.
Each video he finished, he’d add another
two topics to a list of ideas he kept, planning
to just perpetually churn out content until
he eventually had a huge hit that went viral.
Although the one thing he didn’t realize
until it was perhaps too late, was that social
media success didn’t happen overnight.
In fact, it didn’t happen over many, many
nights either.
No matter how often Holden promoted his channel
on his social media profiles, or how many
new videos he uploaded, he couldn’t seem
to get any to land well and get boosted in
the algorithm.
At least, that’s one of the things he attributed
the problem to; he pointed the finger of blame
at anything that he could.
One day it was that the algorithm was suppressing
his channel and boosting others who had already
got more subscribers.
The next it might be his slow internet connection
had led to one of his videos going live at
a time when the site had low traffic.
The one possibility that Holden didn’t stop
to consider was that maybe his genre of content
was too niche, or that the days of the internet’s
interest in lost media had already peaked
back when he was still in high school.
Nevertheless, he kept trying, making content
day in and day out, working under the assumption
that, if he just made enough videos, then
one day one was sure to blow up.
That would be his big break, his ultimate
win, a video that did well enough to garner
thousands, if not millions of views.
But the more time he devoted to HellHolder98,
the only number that seemed
to be at all increasing
was the number of videos he had posted, each
one barely garnering view figures that were
above a single digit.
To make matters worse, getting help with growing
his online brand was next to impossible.
Every now and then, he would post on forums
asking for advice, or if anyone wanted to
collaborate so he could gain some exposure
from creators with bigger followings.
Those posts were often met with a slew of
apathetic, snide responses, or comments telling
Holden to just ‘make better content’ as
if that was solid, specific advice.
On top of that, his mom had outright refused
to support her son’s chosen career path,
citing his failure at school as the main reason.
Speaking of, any friends Holden previously
had at school had all moved away in the years
since, going off to pursue college and other
higher education, some were even starting
their new and exciting professions.
The old saying said ‘it’s lonely at the
top’, but Holden was just as lonely down
at the bottom, posting his content in total
obscurity as if he was just shouting into
an empty void, with no-one around to hear.
The few people Holden did still consider his
friends were all as chronically online as
he was, most of them fellow lost media collectors.
After interacting with them in the comment
threads of various forums, the handful of
like-minded guys were as close as Holden had
to people actively supporting his channel.
The collectors would usually give him pointers
or topics to discuss in videos and contributing
to the single digit view count underneath
his uploads.
Although, to him, it wasn’t nearly enough;
he didn’t want just his friends to see his
videos, he wanted an audience, a fanbase all
of his own.
It was late, the light of the computer monitor
illuminated the dark of Holden’s bedroom.
Hunched over his desk, he was clicking and
dragging clips into the timeline of a video
project, trimming them down to make the whole
thing better paced, snipping out bad takes
where he stumbled over his words or misspoke.
It was while editing that Holden noticed another
screen lighting up on his desk, accompanied
by a vibration; his phone.
He reached for it, seeing a notification pop
up on the locked screen.
It was from Goath, one of the lost media
collectors
and it read:
“Dude, urgent!
Found something that you can make a video
on!”
Holden sighed; it was late, and he was already
focused on editing this current video tonight.
If he got it finished, then he could go to
sleep.
“What do you know about the Deathly Video
Tape?”
Goath asked in a second message, before Holden
even had a chance to open the first.
“The what?” he replied bluntly, before
sending another text saying: “Can’t this
wait until the morning?
I’m trying to edit.”
“If you don’t act fast, it’ll be gone
forever!”
came the response only a second later, followed
by a link.
Lethargically, Holden tapped the hyperlink
Goath had sent, his phone opening up its browser
and displaying the webpage.
It was a buy and sell website, one of those
places where people offloaded junk they didn’t
want anymore to strangers for a bit of extra
cash.
The page in question showed a few grainy photos
taken on a phone of a small, rectangular object
in someone’s hand.
“What is that?”
Holden asked.
“It’s a video tape, bonehead.”
Goath fired back; although they’d never
met in person, Holden always got the sense
his friend was a little older than he was.
Looking back on the seller’s ad, it was
for a second-hand Sony Color Collection 60-90
min Mini DV video tape, a type of cassette
used in a lot of old handheld recording cameras.
“So, what?”
Holden asked in another text.
“Look, there have been rumors for ages about
something called the Deathly Video Tape,”
Goath replied in a series of rapid-fire messages.
“It used to be all the rage on of a lot
of old lost media forums, the real nasty ones
before they got shut down.
Supposedly, there’s a recording on this
tape of some kind of live show.
Except, when you put it in your VCR and press
play, you see something horrible.
Nobody’s ever known if it’s real or just
a legend.”
“How do you know this is the same tape?”
Holden queried; by now, he had typed out the
same link on his computer, and was looking
at the ‘for sale’ page on the bigger screen
while he texted back and forth with Goath.
“Read the item description,” he answered.
Holden’s eyes scanned down the page, finding
a short message from the seller.
“To anyone interested, I am giving this
old Mini DV tape away.
I don’t know where I got it, or why I watched
it, but I wish I hadn’t.
It had ruined everything for me, it’s impossible
to enjoy anything else now that I’ve seen
what’s on it.
Let me make this clear, I am not selling this
tape; I am giving it away free of charge.
I hope that getting rid of it will help.”
“Sounds ominous,” Holden texted.
“If you’re so sure it's this Deathly Video
Tape, then why don’t you get it.”
“Keep reading,” Goath responded.
Underneath the item description was another
note that the seller had written:
“Please note, I am unable to leave my town
at present, nor can I mail this tape to anyone
even if you pay postage.
Collection only, if you are interested, please
contact me at the following address.”
Below was an address; it was in Holden’s
hometown, only a few streets away from where
he and his mom lived.
“This could be it, dude,” came another
slew of messages from Goath.
“You buy this tape and make a video reacting
to it, then you might finally go viral.
But you better be quick, before someone goes
and picks it up thinking its just an ordinary
tape.”
Holden looked back at the address, double-checking
where it was.
At most, it’d take a quick walk there and
back, he thought.
And if this tape was as exclusive as Goath
said it was, then owning it would mean Holden
would be the only one who could make a video
featuring it…
After messaging the seller the night before,
Holden found himself rushing around through
his quiet neighborhood to the address.
All night, as he’d tried to sleep, he kept
thinking of the video he was going to make,
how it could finally put him on the map and
at long last bring him the e-fame he’d been
working towards.
Rapping his knuckles against the front door,
he was met by an older man who stood on the
other side.
He was walking with a crutch, with a few bruises
and stitched-up cuts on his face.
The second that Holden explained he was there
for the tape, the man reached to an unseen
shelf just inside the doorframe and thrust
the rectangular cassette into his hands before
shutting the door as quickly as he could without
it hitting Holden square in the face.
He stared at the tape in his hands; through
its transparent green plastic case, he could
see a hand-scrawled note:
“I know you’ll ignore me if I tell you
not to watch this,” it read.
“So, if you do, then on your own head be
it.”
Having spent the rest of the day looking up
exactly what he’d need to play such an old,
outmoded recording format, and convert the
footage to digital so he could include it
in his video, Holden had retrieved his mom’s
old VHS player from the attic, wiping the
thick layer of dust of it.
It took a while for him to get everything
ready to go; not just finding the right adapters
and cables to hook the VCR up to his TV, as
well as linking that to his computer, plus
angling his camera right and making sure the
ring light he’d bought for filming was putting
enough focus on his face.
After the substantial prep, Holden took a
deep breath, summoning up the faux excitement
and staged smile, before he hit the record
button on his camera.
“What’s up guys, it’s HellHolder98 here!
Now, today I’ve got a real treat for you
all.
So, my friend Goath – shout out to him – told
me that a while ago there was a lot of talk
about something called the Deathly Video Tape.
We found a Mini DV that we think might be
that very same tape, so we’re gonna watch
it and see if it’s legit!”
Dropping his persona as his face turned away
from the camera, Holden punched the play button
on the VHS player, his eyes as glued to the
TV screen as the camera’s lens was fixated
on him.
“Okay, nothing so far,” he observed, met
with nothing but a blank, black screen.
Suddenly, after twelve seconds of nothing,
the playback started instantly, and Holden
started relaying what he was seeing on the
tape to the camera.
There was no sound, either because the recording
on the videotape was filmed that way, or Holden
hadn’t properly figured out how to hook
up the VHS.
The video itself showed a recording of Sesame
Street Live, and for the most part just seemed
pretty underwhelming.
Characters were up on stage, their puppeteers
managing to stay out of sight as they entertained
their young audience.
After two and a half minutes, Holden was starting
to feel like he’d gone to all this effort
over what seemed to just be someone’s old,
unwanted home video.
Just as he was considering turning off the
camera and throwing the videotape in the trash,
at almost the three-minute mark, something
weird started happening on stage.
The actor playing one of the bigger characters
seemed to be having some trouble, instantly
trying to pull off his cumbersome costume,
much to the distress of the kids in the audience,
looking on in horror.
But it wasn’t just that the illusion had
been broken, the actor was trying to get out
of his costume because he was choking.
He dropped to his knees on stage, clawing
at his own throat before
finally falling face-down.
Totally still, asphyxiated… dead.
Over the next almost twenty seconds, the same
thing started happening to another three of
the characters on stage, all of them violently
choking while the children in the audience
screamed and cried silently on the inaudible
tape.
Then, at three and a half minutes, the video
cut out.
Holden was unsure how to react, at first a
little creeped out, only to be somewhat bemused.
He played it down for the camera, remarking
that the video seemed tame compared to some
of the other more graphic, faked content he’d
seen.
But the whole time, even after wrapping recording,
sitting awake all night to edit his reaction
video, blurring out the parts that would break
terms of service, he had no idea if what he’d
seen was actually real or not.
Finishing the final edit just as the sun was
coming up, Holden hit upload and crawled into
bed while his video was uploaded.
The buzz of a text message from Goath awoke
him.
“Dude, I told you this video was going to
make it big!”
Without even replying, Holden booted up his
computer and opened the page for his newly
uploaded video.
The view count was already in the thousands
and climbing, comments pouring in underneath;
mostly from people debating whether or not
the contents of the tape had been faked.
Holden punched the air in excitement; he’d
finally done it.
But as the video kept playing, he heard a
retching sound coming from the computer’s
speakers.
He turned to look back at his earlier self,
filmed only the night before.
Except what he was seeing play out on screen
now wasn’t what he remembered happening
last night, it couldn’t have… because
the Holden in the video was choking.
That wasn’t possible, he was alive and watching
his own video right now, but somehow the footage
was showing him dying, his airway blocked,
face turning red then blue as tears streamed
down his cheeks.
In the video, HellHolder98 fell down, dead
from asphyxiation… and watching it made
Holden feel sick.
To make matters worse, none of the comments
under the video seemed to have witnessed the
same ending.
Holden even texted Goath to ask if the same
thing had happened, but he described the ending
exactly as Holden remembered filming it.
But afterwards, it didn’t stop happening.
Everything he watched ended the same, every
clip online, every TV show, every movie, Holden
couldn’t even read a book without some character,
fictional or otherwise, keeling over and choking
to death, just like the characters on the
tape.
He barely had time to acknowledge the hits
his reaction to the Deathly Video Tape were
getting.
He was too busy trying to figure out why he
couldn’t stop seeing people dying the exact
same way, even himself when he watched back
his old HellHolder98 videos.
‘Reacting to the Deathly Video Tape’ garnered
a respectable three million
views, but HellHolder98
never uploaded again afterwards.
His channel went silent, remembered only as
a one-hit wonder until the video, and the
entire channel were taken down.
Holden was never reported missing, the Foundation
made sure of that when they came by to collect
SCP-583, and placed the
video tape into containment…
Hey, do you have a favorite reality show?
Oh come on, don't lie, everyone has one.
Dr. Clef loves some American Ninja Warrior,
and I’ve got it on good authority that Dr.
Bright can’t get enough of The Bachelor,
so how about you, huh?
Do you obsessively follow the romantic highs
and lows of Love Island, or are you more the
type who likes to curl up with a mug of hot
cocoa and enjoy a nice, wholesome episode
of The Great British Baking Show?
Do you ever yell at the TV when the contestants
on Jeopardy just can't get the answer right?
Do you get a kick out of seeing what crazy
collectibles will show up on this week's episode
of Pawn Stars?
If you answered yes to any of these, you're
not alone - Millions of people around the
world still tune in to all kinds of reality
TV.
Personally, I just can't get enough of my
favorite hidden camera show: Laugh is Fun.
What's that?
You've never heard of Laugh is Fun?
Oh, boy.
You're really missing out.
If you like reality TV, you're gonna love
Laugh is Fun.
Laugh is Fun, also known as SCP-2030, isn't
a show that you can watch on TV.
Instead, it appears as the most popular form
of media distribution in the current year.
Today, you can find it on file-sharing and
streaming websites, but in the 2000's, you
could rent it from the DVD kiosk at the mall,
and back in the ‘90s, it used to show up
as multi-tape sets in video rental stores.
Even though the SCP foundation has only been
aware of Laugh is Fun since 1993, it has a
recorded 38 seasons as of 2014, meaning that
it may have existed in some form as far back
as the 1970s.
If you want to binge all 38 seasons, you might
also want to look it up under the names Laugh
is Life, or, in some countries, Laugh is Laugh.
And if you happen to be in a country where
Laugh is Laugh isn’t available, you may
want to try changing your location using a
VPN to one where you can access it… oh,
what’s that?
You don’t HAVE a VPN service?
Well then I’m glad you’re here, because
before we go any further I have a very important
word from our sponsor who just so happens
to be NordVPN, the preferred VPN service of
all the researchers here at SCP Explained,
sign up now at nordvpn.com/SCPExplained .
NordVPN isn’t just a VPN, it’s truly the
BEST VPN available.
With a simple click, you’ll be able access
content that might be blocked just because
of your location, so you’ll never have to
miss an episode of your favorite anomalous
television programs.
But wait, there’s more, much, much more!
What if you’re right in the middle of binge
watch of Season 31 when suddenly your quality
dips to looking like a couple of blurry blocks
are fighting over an old shoebox.
Never fear, because NordVPN encrypts ALL your
traffic.
That means your internet service provider
can’t throttle your service and slow down
your streaming speed.
You should never settle for less than the
highest quality pixels after all.
And it doesn’t matter how you choose to
watch, NordVPN is available on every modern
platform including Windows, iOS, Android,
macOS, Linux, and even Android TV.
The monthly cost is the same as a cup of coffee,
regular coffee that is, not the kind that
comes from SCP-294, and if you sign up by
going to nordvpn.com/SCPExplained you’ll
even get a free month!
So go try it for yourself right now, that’s
nordvpn.com/SCPexplained
Now, back to your regularly scheduled programming.
As we were saying,
Laugh is Fun is a prank show that puts unknowing
everyday people into ridiculous scenarios
and films their reactions.
Each episode is about 10 to 12 minutes long
and features an opening and closing monologue
from beloved, supposedly human TV presenter
Laughy McLaugherson, aka SCP-2030-1.
You've probably seen him before, he's never
seen without his blue three-piece suit and
black wing-tipped shoes.
Funniest guy on TV, seriously, I think he
should replace James Corden on the Late Late
Show.
And maybe even take up a hosting gig on SNL,
if he’s still got time after.
He had this amazing monologue at the end of
an episode in season 32.
“Ha!
What a ride, eh, folks?
We've seen printers that eat, eaters that
print, and everything in between!
Makes you appreciate the old clunker you have
back the office, doesn't it?
No, printers may not always work when you
want or need them to, but they sure make for
some excellent comedy.
And that's what we're about here: comedy.
We're here to make you laugh.
We hope you laughed.
Thank you for laughing with us.
That's what we're about here, doesn't it,
folks?
Come laugh with us again next time!
And remember: LAUGH … IS … FUN!
Good night!
And laugh!
Just laugh!
We love the make laugh.
Make more for laughter so as to for laugh.
Laugh with us.
Laugh with us!
Laugh!
Laugh and let us in!”
Hmmm.
I couldn't tell you what his face looks like,
though, because he's always framed from the
neck down.
Once the pranks are done for the episode,
he'll step up on that bright yellow stage
and deliver his closing monologue, which always
ends with a pan over the audience as everyone
chants “Laugh with us!”
Then the show always just cuts to black.
The closest thing the show ever has to credits
is a title card that says “Filmed in front
of a studio audience in
partnership with YWTGTHFT.”
For a show that doesn't advertise or even
air on TV, Laugh is Fun is still a beloved
classic, and when you watch it, it's easy
to see why it's been around so long.
Laughy and the team pull off some really classic
pranks on Laugh is Laugh!
There's this one episode in season 13, where
an unsuspecting family is sitting down to
dinner.
The father starts choking, and the family
reacts with horror, until suddenly a pair
of slits appear on the father's neck, allowing
him to breathe.
Those slits soon become nostrils, and before
you know it, a full second head grows out
of his neck.
That head then grows its own neck, which grows
a nose, then a face, then another head, then
another neck.
This keeps happening a total of 18 times while
the rest of the family looks on in horror.
But don't worry, before things go too far,
Laughy pops out from under the table and tells
the family that they're on Laugh is Fun.
Laughy points out the cameras, and the whole
family starts laughing, including all 18 of
the father's heads.
There's another great season 13 episode called
“Squirrels.”
Oh, man, that one had me in stitches!
Alright, so there's this couple lying in bed,
and the wife wakes up because she hears this
squeaking noise.
She taps her husband on the shoulder to wake
him up, but she draws her hand back in horror
because she can feel something moving under
her husband's skin.
Before she can ask if he's okay, boom!
Hundreds of squirrels explode out of his skin
and start running around the room while the
wife screams.
Then Laughy walks in and turns the lights
on, accompanied by the husband, who is perfectly
okay even though he's been skinned from head
to toe.
Everyone laughs.
Then there's a more recent episode from season
24, called “Swelling.”
There's this old lady sitting on a park bench,
feeding the pigeons, and a couple walks past
her.
While they walk past, the old lady gets swarmed
by the pigeons she's feeding.
The pigeons force themselves into her mouth
and keep swarming until her stomach cavity
bursts open.
The couple, who get sprayed with guts as all
the pigeons fly off, are extremely distressed
by this until Laughy shows up.
Some people say that this episode is too similar
to Squirrels and that the show was starting
to get stale at this point, but I think the
joke is unique enough to stand on its own.
Plus, with a prank show as long-running as
Laugh, it's inevitable that you're gonna see
some jokes get reused.
Really, it's not about the prank itself, it's
about the reactions of the people, which are
always priceless!
And man, the way that Laughy McLaugherson
comes into the frame by climbing out of the
old lady's open ribcage?
I was rolling on the floor!
Oh, you don't think the old “animals exploding
out of people” bit is funny?
That's fair enough.
Let me think - what are some of my other favorite
episodes of Laugh is Fun?
Oh - the Margaret Thatcher episode from season
21!
That's another great thing about Laugh is
Fun, it's not afraid to get a little political.
So, this woman walks into her kitchen and
opens the cabinet, but instead of food being
in there, it's just a big blob of flesh.
The flesh blob rolls out onto the counter
and morphs into a misshapen caricature of
Margaret Thatcher with a disproportionately
big head.
The woman starts screaming, but the Thatcher
creature jumps onto her, pinning her down
and shoving its tongue into her mouth.
The deeper the tongue goes, the more Margaret
Thatcher faces start appearing all over the
woman's skin.
All of the faces start reciting Thatcher's
April 1986 speech on the bombing of Libya
in perfect unison.
You might watch it and think the woman's going
to choke based on how long the creature's
tongue is down her throat, but good ol' Laughy
comes in, and the studio audience goes nuts!
Laughy points out the cameras, says “You're
on Laugh is Fun!” and the woman starts laughing
too, with the creature's tongue still in her
mouth.
But I think my favorite prank I've ever seen
on Laugh is Fun was this one from season 37.
So, it's in a hospital.
There's a woman getting a c-section and all
the doctors are gathered around.
One of the doctors makes a comment on how
much hair the baby has, then he screams and
drops his surgical tools.
The rest of the team all start screaming as
well, and then- this is where it gets really
funny- you see Ryan Seacrest's head pop up
out from the woman.
This is causing her a lot of pain, obviously,
so she starts screaming and crying as the
Ryan Seacrest head fully emerges, at which
point you can tell that it's his head on an
octopus' body!
Classic bait-and-switch, right?
But that's not the end- the Ryan Seacrest
octopus starts singing 'Row Row Row Your Boat'
as it emerges, then three more octopi with
celebrities' heads come out of this woman.
There's one that looks like Jack Nicholson,
one that looks like Johnny Cash, and one who
looks like Martin Freeman, and when they've
all come out of her they start singing together
in four-part harmony.
It's hilarious!
Laughy walks in to point out the cameras,
and all the doctors start laughing.
Even the woman on the operating table is laughing.
In fact, she laughs so hard she passes out!
It's a real shame that there are never any
end credits because it would be so cool to
find out more about the people who make this
show.
I mean, they're total comedic geniuses, and
special effects wizards, too.
I couldn't even guess how they do some of
those pranks!
But sadly, there's very little information
about the show online, and you can't even
ask the victims of the pranks about it, because
all of them are dead.
What?
No, no, not because of Laugh is Fun!
That's just a prank show, it's all jokes.
They always show everyone laughing and perfectly
okay at the end, no matter how badly they
got mutilated in the episode.
You can even see some people who had been
on previous episodes among the studio audience
if you look hard enough!
But, by total coincidence, everyone who features
on Laugh is Fun eventually dies, or is already
dead, of totally unrelated causes.
Like the Turman family- the dad, Gary Turman,
was the one who had 18 extra heads grow out
of his neck.
Gary, his wife Lindsey, and their two kids
tragically passed away in a car wreck on the
28th of April, 1989.
Melissa and Travis Englund- the couple from
the squirrel prank went missing and were last
seen on the 12th of May, 1989.
The couple from the pigeon prank- Macey Gersham
and Kyle Parker- were both killed by a hit
and run driver in September of 2000.
Doris Carter, the woman from the Thatcher
prank, passed away from ovarian cancer in
1997, and Rebecca Nash, the woman who gave
birth to all those singing celebrity cephalopods,
died in childbirth in 2013.
You might think that last one had something
to do with her Laugh is Fun episode, due to
the hospital connection, but the surgeons
present when she died didn't report anything
strange happening at the time.
All of these deaths happen in roughly the
same years that all of these people had their
appearances on Laugh, but because it's only
available on streaming and video, it can't
really be said what the connection is since
there aren't air dates for any of the episodes.
While you might assume that these people died
after their appearances on Laugh, and the
show is actually some kind of death curse,
it's just as likely that they died before,
and Laugh is Fun is somehow filmed and distributed
from the great beyond.
Some people even think that the people who
film Laugh actually kidnap all the people
who appear on the show and fake their deaths
in some kind of big sinister conspiracy.
Sure, I have heard that all of the people
who supposedly 'died' after being on the show
have inconsistencies in their death records
and that many of their graves actually just
hold empty coffins, but still, that feels
totally unrealistic to me.
I mean, come on, can you really picture TV's
own Laughy Laugherson kidnapping anyone?
He has such a friendly attitude!
Like I said before, no information whatsoever
exists about the way this show is made.
Not even the SCP foundation has any answers
- they're still actively investigating the
ways in which people get chosen to be on Laugh
is Fun, as well as where it's filmed, and
who produces it.
Talk about a really niche cult hit!
I hope I've sold you on Laugh is Fun.
It may not be that well known, and you might
have trouble finding it, but trust me- it's
the funniest prank show you'll probably ever
watch.
I guarantee, once you get into it, it'll make
you laugh, and laugh, and laugh.
Laugh with us!
Have you ever wanted to be a cartoon?
They have it easier than we do, that’s for
sure.
The characters in your favorite shows never
seem to experience boring days, and the world
around them always seems so wonderful and
imaginative.
Animation is an idealized, stylized form of
reality, where anything can
happen, and entertainment
is at the forefront of the lived experience.
If you’re understanding the appeal behind
what we’re talking about, you’ll definitely
be interested in hearing about SCP-6080, a
strange anomaly known as Eric’s Cartoon
Box.
The story of Eric’s Cartoon Box is elaborate
and complex, but catalogs one of the Foundation’s
most imaginative and surreal anomalies on
file.
It started on Parawatch.net, a message board
dedicated to the supernatural and paranormal
that the Foundation likes to keep tabs on
in their spare time.
While sifting through countless fake posts
about being abducted by aliens or hunting
for bigfoot, the Foundation noticed something
less conventional that caught their eye.
A series of posts that talked about a “cursed”
VHS tape of the mid-90s classic Nickelodeon
cartoon “Rocko’s Modern Life”.
Now, a cursed cartoon seems like your standard
internet horror fiction fare, something the
Foundation could easily dismiss as a story
crafted by an amateur author, but what caught
their attention were the pictures of strange
entities that appeared as a result of watching
the tape, as well as information on how the
original poster obtained the tape.
It seemed oddly specific.
A tape purchased on eBay through a seller
named “tooncollector”.
The Foundation conducted a brief investigation,
and found that “tooncollector” was a resident
of Bakersfield, California named Jacob Sawyer,
who had gone missing some time in the past.
Inside his house, the Foundation found several
VHS tapes and DVD cases, as well as a television.
A hard drive on Sawyer’s computer contained
161 hours of brief, edited videos, all reviewing
and commentating on various cartoons.
Seems like Sawyer had a video essay hobby,
but the Foundation was unable to locate any
of this content on major video hosting sites.
In Sawyer’s basement, the Foundation discovered
a large, worn-out cardboard box.
On its right side were the words “Eric’s
Cartoon Box”, written in black sharpie.
On its front was a simplistic smiley face,
also drawn in sharpie.
Originally, the Foundation thought it was
just an ordinary box, but the object quickly
proved itself to be alive, capable of speaking
despite a lack of vocal cords and also possessing
a degree of mobility, propelling itself short
distances to move.
When the Foundation first came across SCP-6080
in Sawyer’s basement, the object was clearly
distressed.
SCP-6080 and all of the other items found
were taken into Foundation custody, and moved
to Site-433, where they would be researched
by Dr. Rowan Raster, one of the Foundation’s
leading figures in the study of animated anomalous
media and art.
Raster’s research found that SCP-6080, when
emotionally distressed, could bend reality
to alter their surroundings,
which were transformed
into reflections of its psyche.
Raster discovered that there were a few ways
to pacify SCP-6080, but the most practical
method was to evoke a sense of nostalgia in
the object by placing it
in a familiar environment.
To ensure that the box is kept passive, SCP-6080
is kept inside a containment chamber resembling
a child’s bedroom, an environment SCP-6080
finds comforting.
On top of their reality-bending abilities,
SCP-6080 also produces DVDs and VHS tapes,
labeled SCP-6080-1.
The Foundation would later discover that the
tapes found within Sawyer’s home and the
“cursed” Rocko’s Modern Life tape discussed
on Parawatch.net were all products of SCP-6080.
But what’s so special about the cartoon
reproductions made by SCP-6080?
On the outside, they’re unaltered copies
of animated children’s television shows
and films, and their contents are exactly
the same as their ordinary counterparts.
However, once an instance of SCP-6080-1 is
viewed, the subject watching it will experience
a reality-altering anomalous experience dubbed
by the research team as a “Rerun Event”.
Sometimes, the Rerun Event occurs immediately,
though research has shown that as much time
as 3 weeks can pass before one occurs.
Rerun events often reflect visual or thematic
elements of the media that induced them, and
their severity ranges from inconsequential
to dangerous and harmful to their subjects.
Because of the variety found in a Rerun Event’s
content, it’s difficult to generalize them,
but we’ll be sure to get into the specifics
of a few later on.
Still, even if the Event isn’t immediately
dangerous to the subject,
the Foundation discovered
that a Rerun Event may leave involved persons
with lingering physical and psychological
alterations, some of which are unable to be
fully alleviated or treated, even with amnestics.
Soon after SCP-6080 was brought into Site-433
and the immediate characteristics of the anomaly
were recorded, an interview between the box
and Researcher Rowan Raster was held.
Rowan tried to make sure the anomaly was as
comfortable as possible, but SCP-6080 continued
to shuffle against the floor rapidly, unsettled
in their new environment.
SCP-6080 wanted to get out, and the object
continued to stress themselves out, to the
point where its speech degraded
into unintelligibility,
the lights in the containment chamber began
flickering on and off, and the face on the
front of the box rapidly flipped between different
expressions.
Rowan continued trying to get through to SCP-6080,
and eventually they began to speak.They said
that they were scared, and that they missed
someone that they called Eric.
SCP-6080, once calmed down, explained that
Eric was the center of their universe.
In their own words, SCP-6080 felt, when it
first started existing, that their sole purpose
for being here on earth was to exist for Eric.
They remembered waking up in a bedroom filled
with toys and posters, and immediately knowing
the feeling that they knew what they were
made for and who they were made by.
At first, this was overwhelming, and SCP-6080
began to freak out, but Eric showed concern,
and the box realized that they didn’t want
to upset him.
The most important thing for SCP-6080 was
to not upset Eric.
When Raster asked if they could describe Eric,
the box was unable to, and said that whenever
they tried to talk about Eric’s appearance,
people became confused.
They said that Eric’s skin was blue, and
that he had a purple nose, with dark red eyes
and four thin strands of hair on the top of
his head.
From the way they described Eric, he sounded
exactly like a cartoon character.
Raster asked if this was how SCP-6080 always
saw people, and that seemed to be the case.
SCP-6080 then explained how they used their
abilities to make Eric happy, namely through
producing tapes of Eric’s favorite cartoons
and then playing inside the worlds of the
shows together.
And this continued for a while.
SCP-6080 and Eric would meet the characters
from their favorite shows and adventure through
their worlds, and the two developed a powerful
bond.
But eventually, as SCP-6080 explained, Eric
left.
One day, the box woke up, and their friend
was gone.
SCP-6080 even searched for Eric’s friends,
but found that they were gone too.
Without Eric, SCP-6080 was alone, and they
panicked.
They ran outside the house and began asking
anyone they could find if they knew where
Eric went.
Naturally, the people SCP-6080 spoke to were
terrified.
And SCP-6080 quickly became overwhelmed by
the chaos of the outside world.
And then they found Jacob Sawyer.
Sawyer was, at first, just as scared of SCP-6080
as everyone else was.
But once SCP-6080 opened its flaps and revealed
a trove of old tapes, Sawyer smiled to himself,
and told the box that it would be “useful”,
before picking them up and taking them to
his house.
SCP-6080 was scared, and attempted to flee
from Sawyer.
The more time the box spent with Sawyer, the
sicker it felt.
When Sawyer threw the box in the empty, white
walls of his basement, SCP-6080 was forced
by Jacob to open themselves up and produce
tapes.
For months, this is how SCP-6080 lived.
Alone, in a white-walled room, with white
floors and white ceilings.
Being forced open and used as a dispenser
for the tapes, which Sawyer would sell online.
SCP-6080 stopped their account, and began
crying a substance that resembled blueberry
syrup.
Raster put a stop to the interview, realizing
that the object was clearly experiencing a
form of trauma.
After a break, Raster asked SCP-6080 if they
knew what happened to Sawyer.
The box explained that one day, Sawyer rushed
down into the basement, and demanded SCP-6080
to explain what it was doing to the cartoons
it made.
Apparently, some of the buyers were realizing
that SCP-6080’s tapes were anything but
normal.
Sawyer brutalized the box, and pulled a DVD
from inside them.
But when Sawyer watched the DVD for himself,
all SCP-6080 heard from beneath the living
room was a sharp burst of static and a horrible
scream.
After that, Jacob was gone.
SCP-6080 couldn’t recall what tape they
produced that caused Sawyer to disappear,
nor was one matching the box’s description
found inside the house.
After the interview, the Foundation began
its testing with SCP-6080 inside its containment
chamber.
SCP-6080 would produce a tape, a D-Class personnel
would watch it, and the ensuing “Rerun Event”
was recorded.
During testing, SCP-6080 was escorted from
the room so as to not cause it emotional distress.
Most of these tests were routine.
A D-Class would watch an episode of a cartoon,
such as ChalkZone or the Rugrats, and strange,
reality-altering events would occur.
For example, after watching an episode of
the Rugrats where Chuckie had
difficulty differentiating
his dreams from reality, D-1711 experienced
a Rerun Event in which he was disoriented.
D-1711 claimed everything in the room looked
“tall”, and that they needed to sleep
off the effects of the anomaly.
After laying in the bed, the chamber’s lights
turned blue and purple, and a humanoid entity
wearing a researcher’s outfit was seen facing
the corner of the room, against the wall.
The figure disappeared as quickly as it appeared,
with laughter heard in the distance.
As soon as the figure was gone, D-1711 jolted
awake, and began screaming.
After this, the researcher
observing the experiment
rushed in, and like a concerned parent, began
comforting D-1711.
The researcher assured the D-Class that “nothing
in a dream could hurt them, because it isn’t
real” which was a direct quote from the
Rugrats episode D-1711 watched.
After this, the D-Class and the researcher
came out of their trance state, wondering
how they got inside the containment chamber
and what they were doing there.
The Rerun event had finished, and D-1711 explained
that while they were asleep, they dreamed
events similar to the dreams shown in the
Rugrats episode.
This is just one example of how odd and surreal
rerun events can be.
Another test involving an obscure cartoon
by the name of “King”, resulted in the
entirety of Site-433 undergoing changes that
made it look as if it were a location from
the show itself.
However, the most notable rerun event occurred
when the Foundation tested a tape of “Cartoon
All Stars to the Rescue”, a special featuring
cartoon characters from various shows banding
together to talk about the dangers of children
using drugs.
In order to conduct this test, D-9926 was
sent to a quarantined community away from
Site-433, with only a helmet-mounted camera
and a communication headset. 10 hours after
watching the tape, D-9926 slept inside a bedroom
of the vacant building the Foundation had
brought him to.
He was woken by the sound of the doorknob
jittering, and then several knocks.
D-9926 got up from the bed and opened the
door to find four crude-looking
entities resembling
cartoon characters from the special.
One was Kermit the Frog, who was puppeteered
by a man in a gray hoodie.
Another was a cardboard cutout of Bugs Bunny.
There was a tall, mascot-like Garfield costume,
and a sentient ALF plush.
The four entities crowded D-9926 and began
singing to him in a shrill, high pitched voice
a song about the dangers of doing drugs.
D-9926 was confused, but the trance induced
by the anomaly made it difficult for him to
think straight.
Then, from the open windowsill in the room
came a black boot attached to a long leg.
A fifth entity made its way into the room,
crawling through the windowsill.
It was a tall, gray-skinned humanoid with
wrinkled trousers, a creased shirt, and a
large necktie.
As much as D-9926 could understand, the gray
entity was not from a cartoon.
The gray entity signaled D-9926 towards them,
and the two left the building and the strange
cartoon entities behind.
Outside, the environment was strange, it was
dark out, with only dim street lights illuminating
the spaces between trees at a low angle.
The asphalt path the duo walked on slowly
transitioned to a field of grass.
The gray entity explained that the very nature
of the environment was built around the message
of the cartoon, which was trying to get D-9926
to avoid using drugs.
Somehow, D-9926 needed to find a way to get
out.
As the two moved through the forest area,
D-9926 and the Gray Entity continued to recognize
something was wrong.
Gray explained that it didn’t understand
where they were either, and that when D-9926’s
rerun event began altering reality, it was
pulled away from the place it regularly existed,
and into reality.
D-9926 did not understand, but he was short
on options.
Both of them smelled something horrible, and
the area around them was starting to resemble
the real world less and less.
The sky above the forest was smokey orange-red,
and in the distance, D-9926
could see a luminescent
object resembling a window recessed into a
concrete wall.
The two also heard music, and as they moved
through this dream-like world, they came across
the building in the distance, which was small
enough for them to climb the roof of.
On the roof, there appeared to be a parking
lot, and beyond it, more forest, as if they
never elevated from the ground in the first
place.
The two continued walking.
As the parking lot sloped downwards, they
recognized what appeared to be a city in the
distance.
D-9926 knew that with the altered state of
reality, this city was going to be anything
but normal, but he felt compelled to keep
moving.
It was the only thing the two of them could
do.
D-9926 and the Gray Entity began talking about
the nature of the reality they found themselves
in, and the entity explained that it felt
that trusting its gut and exploring anything
that stood out was probably the right thing
to do in a place that made little actual sense.
They concluded that the location they were
inside had some sort of feelings and goals,
and they just had to go along with its own
internal logic in order to find a way out.
In the distance, the red lights of the city
twinkled in the darkness.
They continued walking.
After about 30 minutes, the red lights of
the city illuminated all of their surroundings,
and they began to see the edifices of concrete
buildings on the other side of the road they
were walking on.
D-9926 didn’t notice them at first, but
when the entity pointed them out, D-9926 realized
they were standing in the middle of a mass
of buildings, with rubble and litter strewn
on the streets beneath them.
Gray wondered if they could use them as shelter.
The two didn’t realize they were being watched
by a figure in the distance.
D-9926 was still confused.
The city was empty, Gray seemed oddly optimistic
about their situation, and things weren’t
looking like they were going to return to
normal any time soon.
Gray commented that they were somewhat interested
in exploring a location different from the
realities and dreams they were used to exploring.
After minutes of nothing, the duo came across
a dead body, laying on top of a rusted metal
wheelbarrow.
D-9926, who was familiar with seeing sights
like these, sighed and continued moving.
Gray told him he could simply walk away, into
the darkness, where they could forget about
this place and emerge somewhere else.
D-9926 wondered if the entity really had that
power.
They came across more bodies, and continued
forward.
If this entity could really whisk D-9926 away
to another place, he was seriously considering
it.
Life as a D-Class was unimaginably dehumanizing.
The figure watching the two of them continued
to observe from a rooftop.
Suddenly, a large sheet metal shelving unit
fell from the overhanging roof of a building,
tipped from its edge by the observing figure.
The shelving unit hit Gray directly, and severely
injured the entity on impact.
D-9926 ran.
He ran through the buildings, only catching
glimpses of the orange figure wielding a thick
pipe running across the rooftops beside him.
The chase continued through the insides of
the buildings, and once D-9926 caught a glimpse
of the pursuing figure, he ran back out.
The entire time, he heard the figure’s high
pitched breathing audibly chasing after him.
More bodies, more red lighting, an endless
city, all while being pursued.
D-9926 found rest inside a warehouse, which
he ran through in an attempt to escape the
entity.
At the far side of the warehouse was a room
resembling SCP-6080’s containment chamber,
but heavily damaged and littered with trash.
The television set in the room switched on,
showing an all white room, similar to the
basement SCP-6080 was found in.
The door to the room was about to be opened,
and D-9926 screamed, before smashing the TV
with a book he threw from across the room.
Upon shattering the screen, the camera feed
went dark.
When it resumed, D-9926 found himself in a
red, misty area, with the figure that had
been pursuing him standing in front of him.
The two stared at each other before the figure
lunged forward at D-9926.
But it then suddenly stopped, and the voice
of SCP-6080 was heard.
The box called out to the figure, which it
recognized as something that resembled Jacob
Sawyer.
SCP-6080 ordered the Sawyer-entity to leave
D-9926 alone.
Except this time, SCP-6080 wasn’t a cardboard
box.
They were a pale-skinned child, drawn like
a cartoon, wearing ordinary clothes.
The box realized that this
place was a manifestation
of its own traumatic experience as it slowly
realized that the entity resembling Sawyer
was stuck inside its own mind.
The box and the entity fought each other,
punching with large, cartoon-like fists.
Until the Sawyer-entity fell to the ground,
coughing up blood.
SCP-6080 realized that this wasn’t actually
Sawyer.
Like everything, this was all a manifestation
of the damage that Sawyer caused.
And with that, the entity left its own body,
flattening until all that was left was its
empty skin.
D-9926 thanked SCP-6080 for saving him, and
the two introduced themselves to one another.
SCP-6080 offered to take D-9926 away from
the Foundation forever.
He took off his recording equipment, and the
two walked away into the sunset.
Inside SCP-6080’s containment chamber, the
object, and D-9926, were nowhere to be found.
Instead, there was a single disc, containing
a message from SCP-6080 to the Foundation.
SCP-6080 told the Foundation that they were
coming to terms with what they experienced
in their life, and that for now, they were
in a place where they could exist without
issue.
Behind them was a playground, where SCP-6080
could act like a kid again, something they
never got to experience as much as they wanted
to.
They told the Foundation that D-9926 was safe,
and happy somewhere else, and that they shouldn’t
look for either of them, because they’d
never find them.
For now, all SCP-6080 needed to do was to
play on the swings, and live at peace with
themselves, until they could grow up.
Inside the disc that the message was contained
on was a sticky note that simply read:
“I hope you understand.”
Video games have come a long way over the
years.
We've gone from the days of Atari and "Pong"
to virtual reality headsets, PS5s, and massively
multiplayer online games where you can fight
horror movies villains, or wage war in a fantasy
land.
You can mine virtual minerals and avoid creepers
in "Minecraft," compete against people all
over the world in "Fortnite" and do whatever
it is people do in "Roblox."
Games used to be a pixelated hero battling
blobby monsters with no discernible facial
features, and now they have graphics so detailed
you can see the freckles on a protagonist's
face and each individual blade of grass.
But there's one thing that hasn't changed,
no matter how much progress games may make:
whenever a shiny new console comes out, everyone
wants to get their hands on it.
It was Christmas season in 1986, "Walk Like
an Egyptian" by the Bangles was at the top
of the charts, Eddie Murphy's "The Golden
Child" was the number one movie in America,
and hundreds of thousands of kids were writing
to Santa - and begging their parents - for
one thing: the Nintendo Entertainment System.
The NES was an 8-bit home video game console,
and the only place to journey through the
land of Hyrule in "The Legend of Zelda" or
help Samus hunt Space Pirates in "Metroid."
But with such an extreme demand for the system,
stores were selling out all over the country.
Anyone who didn't beat the crowds was doomed
to disappoint their kids with socks, with
less flashy toys like dolls or tiny plastic
trucks, or with boring,
non-electric, violence-free
board games.
Well, board games are only violence-free if
you're not playing "Monopoly."
But back to 1986.
Beverly Harrington was a single mom, doing
her best to provide for her son, Jason, and
give him the Christmas he deserved.
She had been picking up extra shifts at the
local diner, making sure to save up all of
the extra money for a real Christmas tree
from the farm just out of town, for a beautiful
honey-baked ham, and, of course, for presents.
She knew that, though he was a shy kid and
would never demand it, Jason desperately wanted
to find an NES under the tree on Christmas
morning.
She got so absorbed in her work, so exhausted
from the extra shifts and
trying to make everything
perfect, that she forgot to do her actual
shopping until the very last minute.
She woke up the morning of December 24 with
a start, her heart jumping into her throat.
She hadn't picked up Jason's present yet!
She threw on her coat and rushed out into
the snowy streets, making her way to the store
and saying a silent prayer that they would
still have one more NES in stock.
Lucky for her, they did!
Less lucky, two parents were already wrestling
for it, fighting each other
with the raw animalistic
rage of two wolves competing for the same
piece of meat.
If she tried to grab it and join in, she could
get hurt, or the console could break apart.
She asked an employee if they had any in the
back, but she already knew the answer from
the exhausted look in his eyes.
There were no more in the back.
There were no more in town, or the next town
over, or the next town over from that.
Not only would she have to get Jason's present
at the very last minute, but she would also
have to get him something he didn't even want.
He would smile and thank her, but she knew
how sad it would make him to go back to school
and hear his friends bragging about their
Christmases.
She shoved her hands into the pockets of her
coat, and began her slow, sad march back through
the snow, trying to come up with what to do
next.
Then, something caught her eye, a brightly-colored
sign reading "Wondertaining Toys."
Beneath it, was a storefront she had never
seen before, and right there in the window,
a video game console.
It wasn't the NES, not exactly, but it looked
so much like it…
She couldn't help herself, she had to go inside
and get a better look.
The store was filled with toys, games, and
puzzles.
They were all inviting, with vivid packaging
and labels depicting children having fun,
but she had never seen any of them before.
Perhaps it was a new brand, and she was one
of the first people to happen upon the store?
It seemed odd for a toy store to open this
close to Christmas, rather than taking advantage
of the shopping season and opening earlier
in the year...But she couldn't dwell on that,
not when she was this close to a solution.
Toward the back of the store, she spotted
the video game console from the window.
The label read, "Pretendo."
So the resemblance to the NES was no coincidence,
this console was intended as a knockoff of
some kind.
She asked the sales clerk, a man with a strangely
wide, unmoving smile, if the console was capable
of running Nintendo games.
"You bet your bottom dollar!"
He replied.
"We don't carry those here, though.
But can I interest you in some of our
Wondertainment
originals?
We have all kinds of games here, and they're
just as good or your money back!
There's a whole world inside each and every
one."
It wasn't what she'd set out to buy, but this
was clearly the best thing Beverly was going
to find this close to the holiday.
She paid the man for the Pretendo console
and a selection of the store's most popular
video games.
He even gift-wrapped it for her in a colorful
box, with a shiny red bow on top.
The next morning, Jason and Beverly sat in
the living room, sipping cocoa and opening
presents together.
She started small, with the classic pair of
new wool socks, and worked her way up to the
big box in the corner.
As Jason tore the paper off, his eyes lit
up with glee.
"Thank you, mom!
Thank you!"
He gave her a huge hug, then looked at her
with nearly manic excitement.
"Can I play it now?
Can I?"
She laughed and promised that after he helped
her clean up the wrapping paper, he could
play his new games.
She was just so glad he was happy with it.
He didn't care that it wasn't the name-brand
console, he knew that this gift was special.
So she was perfectly glad to let him enjoy
it, and she could get started on that ham
for later.
Jason plugged in his brand new Pretendo, and
looked through the games his mom had picked
out for him.
There was "Farmtastic!
Farming simulator", "Historical House Hunter",
"Magic Wizard Quest," "Super Fighters," and
one simply called, "Spooky."
It was emblazoned with the image of a cartoon
ghost in front of an abandoned cabin, and
it piqued Jason's interest.
He had always loved scary stories and legends
about ghosts and things that go bump in the
night.
He decided this would be his first game.
He placed the cartridge in the console and
hit the power button to turn it on.
As he clutched the controller in his hands,
he began to notice something strange.
His room, once decorated in posters of his
favorite movies, turned dark.
The light green walls became rotting wood.
And, for lack of a better way to describe
it, the entire world's resolution began to
shift.
If the world around him had graphics, they
were getting worse.
He could no longer see the screen depicting
the game's main menu, and in fact, the console
itself had vanished.
Somehow, he was standing in the haunted cabin
from the cover of the game.
He looked down at his hands and found the
controller still there.
So, not everything had changed...
Before he could think any more about this
strange new place he found himself in, he
heard the sound of ominous music, seemingly
coming from nowhere.
After a moment, he realized why the sound
of its melody filled him with dread...it was
the kind of music that always played in a
game when an enemy was getting close.
He had to move.
He took a step forward, and he moved through
the space as if it was a real house.
For the time being, it was.
Somehow, he was inside the game.
Which meant...the ghost was coming for him
soon.
He pressed a button on the controller to activate
a flashlight, and followed its beam through
the darkened cabin.
As he walked, looking for clues or any object
he could interact with, he could hear the
music getting louder.
Whatever was coming, it was getting closer.
The flashlight's beam illuminated a scrap
of paper on a small table.
He moved to take a closer look, and could
just barely make out what it said.
"They hide in the darkness.
Find the exit.
Don't stop moving.
"
He heard a sound behind him, and the music
reached a deafening volume.
He whirled around, and saw nothing but the
hall in front of him, bending around a corner.
He knew, from the heavy feeling in the pit
of his stomach and the music that threatened
to rupture his eardrums, that there was something
horrible waiting for him around that corner.
He froze for a moment, then remembered the
letter's words of warning, "don't stop moving."
He took a step toward the corner, then another,
and another.
He shone the light of the flashlight around
the corner, but there was nothing there.
No ghost, no monster.
Nothing.
And then he felt it.
A chill on the back of his neck.
He whirled around, and there it was.
The ghost of the cabin.
It was so much bigger than it had looked before,
wispy white form stretching up to the ceiling,
from wall to wall, its wide dark eyes and
gaping maw of a mouth inches from his own
face.
He screamed and instinctively swung the flashlight
at the spirit, cutting through it with a beam
of light.
The ghost let out a shriek and shrank away
from the glow.
That was it!
He just needed to keep the light on it, and
the ghost couldn't hurt him.
Jason was so thrilled by this little victory
that he didn't notice the boss music starting
to play again, growing louder and louder.
He didn't see the movement out of the corner
of his eye, the silvery pale figure of a woman
stepping out of a portrait on the wall.
All he felt was a sudden, overwhelming cold,
like ice in his veins, and then everything
went black.
He opened his eyes back in his bedroom, looking
at a dark screen with the words GAME OVER
written in dripping red font.
He couldn't tell for a moment if that had
been real or a dream, but either way, he only
wanted to do one thing: tell his mom.
Beverly listened to her son's story, and couldn't
help but write it off as
the overactive imagination
of a child.
But still, she humored him and agreed to try
the console for herself and see what happened.
Choosing at random, she selected "Farmtastic!"
and pressed "play."
All of a sudden, she felt the heat of the
sun on her face, heard the mooing of cows,
and smelled fresh-cut hay.
She was steering a tractor through a wide-open
field, where a moment ago she had been standing
in her house in the dead of winter.
Jason shut off the game, pulling her back
into reality, and as Beverly gaped in shock,
Jason said "Best!
Present!
EVER!"
Unfortunately for Jason, word was already
spreading about the Pretendo, all the way
to the SCP Foundation.
The console, and all other consoles that the
Foundation could track down, were seized and
designated SCP-591.
SCP-591 is a line of video
game consoles originally
developed as a counterfeit of the Nintendo
Entertainment System, before being bought
and distributed by Doctor Wondertainment,
a toy company responsible for a wide variety
of anomalous objects contained by the Foundation
over the years.
The console is capable of playing NES titles
as well as games from Doctor Wondertainment's
original lineup of 8-bit games, many of which
the Foundation has in its possession as well.
Some of the titles in the SCP Foundation library
include, but are not limited to, arcade shooter
"Whap 'Em!", platformer "Dusky's Adventures
in Staedland," survival horror game "You Can
Do That on Television," puzzle game "WWI Ace
Trench Digger," music/racing game "Led Zeppelin
Air Racers," fightings games "Super Kick Karate"
and "Super Kick Karate 2010," and the educational
game "Reading Rainbow Sit and Listen."
Whenever one of the official Doctor Wondertainment
cartridges is inserted into the console and
activated, it results in a localized CK-class
reality restructuring scenario, which rearranges
reality in the immediate area to resemble
the game's setting.
The player inside of the game's affected radius
will take on the role of the game's protagonist,
and navigate the events of the game until
they either win or the console is deactivated.
Don't worry, this isn't one of those "if you
die in the game you die in real life" scenarios.
If the player happens to be a less than adept
gamer, they will simply respawn or start at
the beginning of the game like any video game
character would.
That doesn't, however, mean that SCP-591 isn't
dangerous.
Like any piece of vintage technology, the
components of the Pretendo system have degraded
over time, their functionality
steadily decreasing.
For an ordinary game console, this would be
a simple inconvenience, something that would
impact the quality of the graphics or the
responsiveness of the controls.
It would be annoying, and maybe eventually
unplayable, but otherwise harmless.
For the Pretendo, however, this degradation
has had catastrophic effects.
When a game cartridge is inserted into SCP-591,
there is now a chance of the CK-class reality
restructuring scenario going wrong, and resulting
in a ZK-class reality failure scenario instead.
Essentially, instead of just transporting
the player into the world of the game, reality
will crumble in the designated area and the
laws of time, space, and physics will be bent
or even broken.
While the CK-class scenarios dissipate as
soon as the console is deactivated, the ZK-class
scenarios refuse to play by the rules.
They remain in place wherever
they first manifested,
seemingly permanently.
The ZK-class scenarios were first observed
during play-testing by the research staff
assigned to SCP-591.
After learning about the nature of the Pretendo
game system, Dr. Furakawa has volunteered
as a test subject, specifically requesting
that he be given the chance to play the Dr.
Wondertainment title "The Legend of Sword
Master," because, quote, "It just looks really
cool."
This particular game came with not just the
cartridge, but a special sword-shaped controller,
to be used during the sword fight sequences.
Dr. Furakawa stepped into the containment
cell where one instance of SCP-591 had been
placed, with his chosen game cartridge and
controller waiting for him.
As soon as he inserted the cartridge into
the console and pressed the "start" button,
the room around him began to transform, reality
itself warping and reshaping to fit the world
of the game.
Fluorescent lights and stark white walls were
replaced by pixelated trees, and a winding
cobblestone path leading to a massive stone
castle.
The first enemy, a knight in black armor,
leaped into frame, and Dr. Furakawa raised
his sword, ready for combat.
But before he had a chance to deal the first
blow, it became clear that something wasn't
right.
The enemy knight suddenly disappeared, glitching
out of sight.
The cobblestones slowly began to drift into
the air, and so did Dr. Furakawa.
Just as suddenly as he lifted off, he dropped
back to the ground with a heavy thud.
Gravity was rapidly fluctuating, and he could
scarcely keep his balance.
In front of him, he could see random cubic
structures popping up out of nowhere, made
up of wood, stone, and ice.
"End the game!"
He called out desperately.
"Pull the plug, someone, please!"
Outside, one of the researchers watching the
experiment cut the power to the console, but
nothing happened.
The world refused to return to normal.
Security officers entered the area, and attempted
to remove Dr. Furakawa, but found that his
body still resembled an
8-bit video game character.
When they attempted to drag him out of the
ZK-class zone, he cried out in pain as his
body began to dissolve into static.
They had turned off the console, but they
were unable to pull him out.
The rest of the research team, horrified by
what they had witnessed,
began to take measurements
of the reality failure scenario from outside
of the room.
The area now displayed a complete absence
of naturally occurring radiation, including
cosmic background radiation.
There was also evidence of time dilation,
reduction of light speed, and the gravity
fluctuations that Dr. Furakawa had first noticed.
With no way to remove Furakawa from this broken
reality, the area would have to be sealed
off, and he would be left inside.
There was no other option.
So, they constructed a concrete dome around
the testing site, and relocated the remaining
instances of SCP-591.
From that point on, testing was only conducted
using D-Class, no matter how much research
staff loved video games, or how vehemently
they insisted that they were "willing to roll
the dice."
They were barred from testing and encouraged
to pick up a VR headset for a much lower-risk
immersive gaming experience.
Over the years of testing following the Dr.
Furakawa incident, four more ZK-class scenarios
were created and contained.
Some of the individuals survived the incident
but were physically altered so greatly that
they would not be able to survive outside
of the ZK-class reality failure.
The only people who survived were unable to
readjust to their lives, continuing to live
as the main character of the game they were
playing.
At this point, testing was officially suspended
indefinitely, due not only to the loss of
human life but also the unpredictable and
highly dangerous nature of the damage being
done to reality on such a grand scale.
All instances of SCP-591 confiscated by the
Foundation are kept in a storage containment
vault, kept separate from any civilians or
their infrastructure by a distance of at least
500m.
It is also kept separate from
other Foundation-controlled
containment facilities.
Unless it is being used for official, approved
testing by Level-3 staff, it is to remain
deactivated at all times.
Any ZK-class scenarios created by an instance
of SCP-591 will be contained via the construction
of a closed concrete dome,
and given the designation
of Sector-W#.
Sectors W1 through W5, the currently existing
ZK-class scenarios, are monitored remotely
and kept highly classified.
Any personnel or test subjects located inside
one of these sectors will
remain there indefinitely,
and be officially considered lost in action.
Any additional instances of SCP-591 located
in civilian stores, households, or any public
place are to be removed and contained immediately.
As the years have gone by, testing has indicated
a steady increase in the rake of a ZK-class
scenario being generated from a CK-class scenario.
Where it was once only a 1% chance, there
is now a 32% chance.
According to Wondertainment company records,
seized during a Foundation raid of one of
their toy factories, there are still plenty
of SCP-591 instances out there in the wild,
just waiting for some unsuspecting gamer to
fire them up and get lost in the story, literally.
If the documents found are accurate, there
are around 243 consoles and 1,300 consoles
still in circulation.
These also may or may not include a "Pocket
Pretendo" model that was developed as a prototype
but never officially released on the market.
If it was, and the chaos of the Pretendo system
is available in a portable form...well, it's
best not to think about that for too long.
The Foundation is doing its best to track
down the remaining Pretendo systems, but there
is no way to know for sure what distant corners
of the world they've made their way to.
So, when you're picking up a shiny new game
console, or a nostalgic vintage model to relive
some of your favorite childhood memories with,
take an extra close look at the label and
make sure you're getting the real thing.
Because if you're not careful...it just might
be Game Over.
Modern cognitive neuroscience tells us that
our memories are about as reliable as as the
weatherman at your local news channel.
When a couple is asked How did you first meet?
they are lured into romanticized reflection.
They might recall locking eyes at a school
dance.
They might recall the night being just perfect…
despite the truth being far from it.
We don’t remember the spilled punch, the
stepped-on toes, or the
stuh—stuh--stuh-stuttering.
We only remember the x’s and o’s.
Our memory doesn’t find the needle by sifting
through the haystack, but rather by lighting
a match and setting the barn ablaze until
all that remains is that small piece of silver,
shining through smoke.
In this way, our memories are our best friends
– they know exactly when to lie to us, feeding
us misinformation about the past to satisfy
ourselves in the present.
Because if humans were capable of writing
and recalling accurate personal accounts of
their history, our memoirs would be stiff,
un-marketable literature.
And when a book gets boring, we tend to tap
out.
Just the same, when our lives get monotonous,
we tend to give up.
So, we have our faulty, biased brains to thank
for our perceived happiness and fulfillment.
Our inaccurate memory systems consequently
help us hide trauma, contrive purpose, and
infuse unique importance into an otherwise
banal existence.
But let it be known, not
all cerebral restructurings
are gifts from psychology.
Some are curses from SCPs.
Which of these two possibilities
is more existentially
terrifying is up to you.
SCP-5040 is a nonexistent Japanese horror
film entitled "Tears of
Blood", which spontaneously
manifests in human memories.
SCP-5040 is a master of persuasion.
Those affected by SCP-5040 will remember going
to see the film even when
their supposed attendance
would contradict empirical evidence.
It manipulates the mind into unwavering faith.
While humans occasionally stumble upon the
self-awareness to question their recollection,
there are no documented instances of an individual
doubting this specific memory.
Somehow, beyond The Foundation’s understanding,
SCP-5040 manages to suspend the skepticism
of its victims.
They accept the memory as canon.
As brute fact.
Victims of SCP-5040 do not need a ticket stub
to know they had been to the theater, and
SCP-5040 afflictions can occur any place where
movies are shown.
It even transcends laws and navigates social
norms.
In cultures where its content would usually
be prohibited by regulations and frowned upon
by the public, it still inserts itself into
the memory of its prey.
And once that memory is planted, it’s an
event that can’t be forgotten.
Like the birth of your first child.
Like your favorite football team winning the
Super Bowl.
Like the employee number you punch in and
out of work every day for the rest of your
life.
It stamps itself into the forefront of the
subject’s brain, waving its arm, pleading
to be recognized, begging for attention.
Descriptions of the film are always similar
in nature, as are the circumstances and events
surrounding the viewing.
However, reports of SCP-5040's
story and characters
are never fully consistent from one subject
to the next, and the film's setting, subplots,
character names, and much of the dialogue
are different for each viewer.
Whether this is SCP-5040’s intent or inadequacy
is unclear.
Casting also varies and appears largely arbitrary;
a broad variety of Japanese performers and
entertainment personalities - both living
and deceased - have been said to star in the
film, even when the actor in question has
no real-life associations with the horror
genre.
Imagine famous Japanese actor, Pat Morita,
better known as Mr. Miyagi from The Karate
Kid, being the lead in a horror film.
Despite the fact this would be a noticeably
strange casting decision, SCP-5040 would still
be taken seriously.
Despite any and all deviations from expectations
of the medium, SCP-5040 is seen as legitimate.
Kinks in its design are overlooked by the
viewer, similar to how our sleeping selves
most often don’t recognize we are dreaming
– even when we encounter flying horses,
friends with banana fingers, and leprechauns
playing pot-limit Omaha in Chris Hemsworth’s
basement.
This may be because, despite all its quirks,
the film's core is sturdy.
Its beginning, middle, and end are always
in agreement.
It doesn’t stray from Robert Mckee's universal
structure of Story.
Not even the sick and twisted M. Night Shyamalan
himself could have created a cinematic experience
quite like this.
After conducting more than
three hundred interviews,
researchers have constructed a detailed synopsis
of SCP-5040's most consistent story elements
and the most common sequence of events associated
with the viewer's memory of their screening
attendance.
There is no matinee with this movie.
Screenings always begin at sunset.
If there are obstacles standing in the way
of a subject's attendance, SCP-5040 will see
them removed.
Dentist appointments, drinks with a friend,
a long-procrastinated date with the treadmill,
all these commitments for that day and time
will be pushed down the subject’s list of
priorities, making way for the movie.
They will learn that their plans have been
canceled or resolved one way or another.
The dentist's office burned to the ground.
Your friend is suddenly sober.
The model of treadmills at your gym has been
recalled.
Somehow, someway, time is freed up.
And when life is kind enough to offer respite
from personal and social obligations, it is
modern humans’ instinct to sit down and
veg out.
At this moment, the subjects decide to see
a movie at a nearby theater.
Upon arrival, the theater looks to be an entity
in its own right.
Long lines of patrons are like limbs extending
from its center box office.
Bright, blocky letters forming the film’s
title run across the marquee like a cheap
tattoo.
It’s madness.
A frenzied crowd gathers at the box office,
pushing and shoving, clawing at the glass
partition for a ticket.
The entire theater has been reserved for this
special event: a one-time-only screening of
a rare, critically acclaimed film.
Drawn in by the excitement, the subject indulges
their curiosity and gets in line for a ticket.
Admission is entirely free.
But is it actually free?
Or has the cost just not declared itself?
When the subject reaches the auditorium, they
scan their eyes over the sea of people.
Heads emerge from the backs of almost every
seat.
They can only find one empty space, and they
have to shuffle like a crab to get past the
mass of other viewers.
In their seat, they notice that a large number
of people throughout the audience are wearing
disposable face masks.
The woman sitting next to the subject’s
right wears one such mask, as does the woman
on their left.
And before you think, “Well, that isn’t
so weird”, it’s important to note that
all of these accounts were taken years before
certain recent events.
Patrons continue to pack into the theater.
Despite every chair being filled, more and
more people enter.
The aisles become overflow seating.
Regulations of Max Occupancy are dismissed.
In the darkness of the room, all that can
be clearly seen are shapes.
The rectangle that is the screen.
The hundreds of circles that are the heads
of the audience.
But also there’s a shape that feels misplaced.
What appears to be the letter “P” sticks
up from the crowd.
A thin line with a bulge protruding from the
top.
The specificity of its origin is difficult
to define.
But once the subject’s eyes adjust to the
dark, they notice it’s an IV pole carrying
a bag of unknown fluid.
However, there is no clear indication of who
it is connected to.
Furthermore, they notice one of the masked
audience members is wearing a hospital gown.
There is little time to assess any of these
strange visuals, because there are no trailers
or advertisements before the film.
As soon as the audience is settled into whatever
space they might find temporarily habitable,
the theater goes silent and the film begins.
The film opens with the female protagonist
going about mundane activities in her day-to-day
life.
A phone call interrupts her.
It’s an unknown party, who tells her that
a loved one has been hospitalized, for one
reason or another.
The protagonist drops what she’s doing to
accept the call to action.
On her way to the hospital, however, she is
attacked by a male assailant
and loses consciousness.
The protagonist wakes up in a fog, unable
to make sense of her surroundings.
But the audience understands that wherever
she is, she’s in deep trouble.
She’s in a desolate and unfamiliar building
with her arms and legs bound.
She is accompanied by a number of other female
captives, some of whom still remain seemingly
unconscious or possibly dead.
The women briefly discuss their strategy to
escape, but they are interrupted when the
kidnapper appears.
Descriptions of hairstyle, eye color, and
wardrobe would fall short in showing us who
this character really is.
Instead, his swift and decisive actions do
the talking.
He sees one of the women crying and kills
her without hesitation.
The kidnapper reveals to the women the code
he intended to operate under.
He would release the captives after 24 hours,
but only under the condition that they do
not cry.
During the film, the kidnapper demonstrates
various forms of physical and psychological
torture on the group of women.
Despite their best efforts, the captives are
unable to hold back their tears, and one by
one they are murdered until only the protagonist
remains.
Frustrated by the protagonist's unremarkable
resolve, the kidnapper takes more extreme
measures, increasing the violence and intensity
of her torture.
However, the protagonist is not one to be
messed with.
Despite being tormented, she seems in control
of the situation.
She doesn’t succumb to the traditional dynamics
of torture.
Even while on the wrong end of the bat, she
isn’t afraid to swing.
She fights back how she can.
She mocks and insults her captive.
And it's then that she finds his weakness.
Although a physically empowering villain,
he is emotionally fragile.
Her grit frustrates him, causing him to lose
focus and become noticeably rattled.
As the protagonist continues to weaken her
kidnapper with words, the subject in the audience
notices what seems to be a slight echo in
the dialogue.
They look up to see if something is wrong
with the speakers.
They even wonder if this is a stylistic decision
made by the director.
But then they notice where it is coming from.
They eventually realize that the two masked
women sitting beside them are quietly repeating
every line of dialogue as it occurs.
Their lips moving causes their masks to shake
softly.
With each word, the air from their whispers
blows the cloth away from their mouth, only
for the mask to collapse back in when the
syllable is completed.
If the subject looks even closer, they will
see that the lower half of the women's masks
are saturated with saliva.
Things don’t get any more pleasant when
the subject shifts their gaze down the women’s
body.
Just near their waists, their hands are clasped
together so tightly that their fingernails
are digging into their skin.
They tremble and fidget as if having taken
on the burden of the world’s anxiety; and
no medication can calm them down.
Fingernails dig deeper into their skin, drawing
blood and foreshadowing the film’s finale.
At the film's climax, the kidnapper approaches
the protagonist with a double edge razor blade
and announces that even if she is freed, she
will spend the rest of her
life horribly disfigured.
This leads to an argument between the two,
the subtext of which alludes to themes such
as the nature of inner and outer beauty, the
value of women in society, and the societal
stigma against expressions of vulnerability.
The argument on the surface, however, does
not sound sophisticated or profound.
There is no consolation for a fight having
emotional depths.
At the end of the day, the blows will always
feel more physical than intellectual.
Eventually, the kidnapper loses patience,
and grabs the protagonist by the shoulders
and slams her to the floor.
He reaches out his hands and grabs her by
the face.
The subject’s attention is again pulled
from the screen when they hear groaning from
every direction.
It sounds like the accumulative grumblings
of every chore in human history ever moaned
and groaned about.
These wordless hums fill the theater with
a sense of worry and uneasiness, so much so
that the subject feels the room getting smaller
as the air polluted with angst grows thicker.
As the subject brings their eyes back to the
film, they see the kidnapper gripping the
protagonist's lower lip between his thumb
and forefinger, squeezing tight as to pop
her lip like a balloon.
The kidnapper then takes the razor blade to
the victim’s lips.
He pauses to mock the protagonist.
And while he does this, blinded by pride and
arrogance, she jolts into action, grabbing
the razor right out of his hands with her
teeth.
She follows up her burglary with assault.
Her neck stabs forward and in a blur, she
stabs the kidnappers' eyes out.
It happens in an instant.
The kidnapper has no time to react.
Blood spills from his face.
Screams pour out of his mouth.
During this time, the protagonist maneuvers
the razor into her fingers.
She hacks away at her bindings, but they are
stubborn and resist her sawing.
The battle continues, and the kidnapper is
able to tear off the victim’s lips entirely.
She looks like a monster now.
As the kidnapper smiles and celebrates his
wrongdoings, the protagonist finishes freeing
herself and slits the kidnapper's throat with
the razor.
The protagonist locates the exit and scrabbles
toward it as the kidnapper bleeds to death
on the cold, hard floor.
The protagonist then speaks her final words.
Due to her injuries, her voice is muffled
and raspy.
She bears down and calmly speaks.
One last time, she mocks the kidnapper, telling
him that he "cried tears of blood" and therefore
had to die according to his own rules.
During this climax, it is reported that subjects
experience a sense of dread unique to any
other terror ever felt.
Strangely, the feeling appeared not to correspond
to the scene in the film at all.
It is a feeling entirely separate from the
viewing experience, as if for a moment the
subject is taken out of the moment in time
and transported to a realm composed only of
fear and anxiety.
But just as quickly as they left, they returned.
The Foundation sees it worth mentioning that
this peculiar moment happens to occur during
the film’s most clearly recalled scene.
While descriptions of violence vary from one
viewer to the next, the climax is unshakable
in its consistency.
This is further evidence that SCP-5040 has
a core foundation that remains intact.
False memories are given validity by our peers.
When we tell a story, the inaccuracies are
often the best parts.
The exaggerated drama.
The rearranged sequence of events.
The jokes you thought of only in retrospect
but weaved into later accounts.
While a storyteller knows when to lie, a good
storyteller knows how not to get caught.
SCP-5040 captivates its audience, but it seems
to know how much it can get away with.
By providing a consistent, objective truth
– a climax that is reported the same across
all accounts – SCP-5040 insists, even if
only briefly, on being a credible film, not
just a random sequence of 24 frames per second.
Eyes back to the screen, the film abruptly
cuts to an unspecified point in the future.
Now wearing a face mask to hide her disfigured
mouth, no different than the ones seen worn
in theater, the protagonist walks down the
street to her apartment, indifferent to the
crowd of paparazzi that follows her.
It’s clear that this is now just a part
of her life.
The lights flash on her face.
When she reaches her bedroom, the protagonist
slowly pulls down her mask.
Face free from cloth, she stares at herself
in the mirror.
It is silent.
What she sees is less notable than what she
doesn’t.
The lower portion of her face is gone.
She focuses on only that.
It’s hard to know if she will ever see into
her own eyes again.
Her gaze might forever be fixed on what she
can’t get back.
And through those eyes that long to see more,
she sheds a single tear.
Over the course of several minutes, her weeping
gradually builds into frenzied sobs and shrieks.
It can first be misinterpreted as bad acting,
a case of doing too much.
But as the crying carries onward, it’s understood
that the horror in her wallowing is all too
real.
The film cuts to black and the credits roll,
but the sound of the protagonist's cries continue
to play with no other audio until the credit
reel ends, and even then, in silence, it’s
hard to say if she ever stopped crying.
Audience members remain silent after the movie
ends, exchanging only whispers as they exit
the theater.
Feet step over small red puddles and stains
on the theater floor as if they are sticky
puddles of soda.
Those who remain past this point experience
an escalating feeling of unwelcomeness, until
sitting and staying is more physically demanding
than getting up and walking out.
Some experiences will stay with you forever,
even if they never actually happened.